My moiboo!
Oh gosh.
Oh my god.
Hi everybody.
Hello.
Hello, hello, hello.
Moiboo, moiboo, moiboo, moiboo, moiboo.
Welcome back.
Welcome home.
And I'm also home.
And I'm just now realizing my voice is so dead.
My boy, I just got back from Off-Kai Expo 2026.
And boy, are my arms tired.
Oh, no.
Oh, it was, it was, it was, oh, it was so much.
It was so much.
I don't think I'm sick, though.
I think I'm okay.
It's just, it was so much.
Talking.
It was so much talking.
Welcome back, it feels like forever since I saw you last.
Spank, I was just looking.
You were like, did you see my kitty from the concert?
And I was reading the messages just earlier, actually.
And I did say your kitty.
I like your kitty.
Wait, I don't even, I don't think I know what your kitty's
name is.
Meow.
Welcome back, Akirale and Mark!
Thank you!
Welcome back, Minto!
You did fantastic at Legends and New Year's.
You sounded amazing.
Your performance of Uramashi Summer was so cute in the MVP
harmonies.
Rumpo, you're proud of your boss.
Thank you, Rob!
Thank you!
Non, thank you!
I guess you have to thank you!
Welcome, Albert.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
we talk a little bit about off kai i don't want to talk too
much his name is jiro chan oh cute cute concert was so
amazing was it really i mean to love the concert excited for
next month too i was watching like the the vod i was
watching the vod just trying to be like wow remembering the
moment because it honestly feels like a bit of a blur
Welcome back, thank you!
Welcome back home, thank you!
Content idea for October, Densetsu EXE Pumpkin Carving
Contest.
I want to know who can make the best, best, the best
jack-o-lantern.
I wonder, can you get the pumpkins for carving in Japan?
We'll have to ask Vicky if that is easy to do.
Oh, my!
Jordan, oh, hello, Vito, and I was like, you!
It was so nice finally getting to meet you!
Thank you!
I had so much fun over the weekend meeting all sorts of
I-Fluz and getting all kinds of Merky merch!
So glad I was able to make it out and the concert was an
all-timer.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Make back, thank you for the gift.
Thank you guys so much.
The concert was absolutely incredible.
You all nailed it.
Nailed it streaming, getting here.
The birthday was...
My birthday was on Tuesday!
Happy Valeta birthday, Senya!
Happy Valeta birthday!
Still in awe over Legends and New.
You, Vicky and Vibro.
Phoebe, you were absolutely brilliant on that stage.
Being there in person for it was a highlight of my year.
That's crazy.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Wow, there's so many.
So many, so many messages, so many specials.
Thank you so much, everybody.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank
you.
Will there be a restocking of the Fumo mint plushie?
I've been wanting one, but it's not in stock at the moment.
I think it was maybe a limited drop, but I would like to
have more plushies in the future.
So, hold out just a little bit longer maybe.
Yes, yes, yes.
Welcome back, Minto.
You were amazing at Legends and New.
I got to watch the pod.
Thank you for being the cutest ghost.
No, thank you for watching.
It was great meeting you.
I was the Tuxedo Snake.
Yes, yes!
Also, Matara choked me.
Oh.
Why?
Why did she do that?
Welcome back.
Welcome home, boss.
Thanks for the first meet and greet in the killer concert.
Rosalind Glitch first!
Thank you!
I hope the spaghetti I spilled wasn't too spicy.
No, you were totally fine.
You were so fine.
Congrats on Legend of New.
I love the show, including watching you perform with your
new song.
All of you were wonderful.
Thank you so much.
We concert was amazing.
Hope I could see a person.
Yes, hopefully one day.
Hopefully one day.
me sorry i'm just like reading all the messages i'm like i'm
like there's so many so many so many so many to catch up on
wasn't because i lost some concert really enjoyed the
performances thank you so much i'm glad you guys thought
that it was worth it that um that it was it was worth going
to off clay for and all also your distance to concert was so
amazing jpeg dog couldn't go to the call me next time shout
into the void say they're not letting jpeg dog in and i will
possess them and say just kidding welcome back me though i
was so shaky and star just struck when i met you what do you
mean love you so much i'm so blessed to finally get to meet
you after having to be financially responsible and passing
on prior opportunities i'm proud of you for being Yes, yes,
yes, yes.
Gotta go rewatch the VOD a million times now.
Thank you.
Wow.
We have another birthday.
Today is my birthday.
Zero on Zero.
Happy birthday.
Wait.
Your profile picture.
Happy, happy, happy.
Happy, happy, happy birthday.
It's Karma from the Mean Grit.
I'm here as promised.
Oh, lovely.
We're so great at the concert.
I hope you enjoyed Disney.
let it maybe maybe
i might have gone down to disney with vicky i might have
been able to show vicky around disney for the first time so
that was really fun oh it was really really fun keeping it
short with a magical weekend thank you it's good so much
thank you thanks for an amazing concert Everyone did great.
My first off, Kai-too.
Glad I got to meet Phoebe.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Frankly, thank you!
Congrats on the successful concert.
You and the other girls did great.
And the new group song is such an earworm.
Loved your do it with Asaka-too.
Thank you.
It was just so crazy.
I can't believe it started.
started with Legends Anu.
I was so nervous.
There's still even things that I was like, you know.
I was watching the bot and I was like, ah.
Everything was amazing.
Thank you, Visible Moose.
Thank you.
Oh, I saw a fantastic concert of Memeni Aivu.
Not only did I get to meet you again, I got to meet Becky
and Phoebe.
Yeah!
Thank you.
was such an unreal accomplishment.
Oh, thank you guys.
You're gonna make me cry for a new one.
Oh,
it was incredible.
Thank you for the amazing show.
I need to buy the Vata rewatch.
Yeah, I mean, no, you don't have to.
You don't have to.
But thanks for making Off-Kai extra fun.
Thank you so much for the pink Torko.
Thank you.
I'm glad you had fun.
I'm so glad you had fun.
You were worth going to Off-Kai for.
You made my Off-Kai amazing.
Just like you did the last...
To Off-Kai before.
Thank you for everything you do.
Welcome, Hobito.
Love you, Hobito.
Thank you, Kabo!
Thank you.
Ofkoi.
I know people are probably wanting to hear Off-Kai stories.
Um.
I think if everybody's Off-Kai was great, then my Off-Kai
was good.
My Off-Kai was very much one of those, um, One of those,
don't ask me how I'm doing, I will burst into tears.
Because it's just sort of scenarios.
But my philosophy is, if everybody, if everybody else had
fun, if it seemed mostly okay on the outside, then it's okay
for me.
Just everything was exploding.
many things exploding i hope shiner gave you the dino brain
he did we actually we were taught we when he gave it to me
he was like i like the i like the postcard daily dial used
staying up till 7 8 a.m for the concert no thank you for
watching it oh thank you Thanks for amazing concert legends
and it was amazing finally got to me.
I was so nervous.
No, don't be nervous seeing me.
Don't be I'm just me.
I'm just me.
I'm just a ghost
Yeah, I don't it was it was a it was a rough off cut this
time for me But I don't want to get into it because I don't
want to seem like a downer or anything.
I did have so much fun meeting everybody though that's
always that's always my highlight um yeah so um and of
course the concert was was so crazy but like i was watching
divan and i was like oh i messed up my dance move there oh
like there was so much dancing it was so much to learn I
have to I was like man I want to Maybe I should take some
dancing lessons Or something
It's a great though You think so?
We didn't notice at all I messed up Dens into MVP's choreos
so much But I was like Wait a second This is everybody's
first time watching it So maybe they won't This is for
everybody's first time seeing the Choreo, so there's no way
that you would know that I messed up.
Bird on Choreo was so good.
That one was tough.
That one was really tough.
When we were practicing it, I thank you guys so much for the
pink.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
I will read, I will keep reading, I will keep reading.
When we were practicing, it was one of those songs where
like, get like frustrated enough where we would have tears
you know we were like i can't get this part welcome back
eggy with the burning on shirt yeah thank you for all some
of the shirts eggy we all got our own shirts thank you
they're so funny i love minky levin you're crazy your tweets
sometimes show up in mine You're crazy and all that...
I see what you're doing.
I think we were all bursting into tears at some point,
incredible experience.
It was really hard.
I had to listen to the intro version of Densetsu MVPs many,
many times.
So that I wouldn't cry hearing it.
You know what I mean?
So that I wouldn't...
Because it's so... I don't know, it's so emo-y.
It was...
It's so emo-y, emotional.
Nah.
Secrets of fooling us is not telling us afterwards.
Should I be quiet?
Can't wait to wipe my glasses every day using the Ace Combat
8 glasses.
Yeah, of course.
They gave the stuff and I was like, oh, I don't feel like I
deserve the Ace Combat stuff.
So I was like, I'll at least try and get the white, the
cleaning cloth to you.
How are you doing?
Wonderful ease.
Super congratulations at the concert.
Thank you!
I didn't meet you off-kind because I live in Canada, but I'm
always happy to see you in any capacity.
You and the Goyles questioned at the concert.
My favorite part was towards the end when you were rolling
on the floor like a baby.
Legends of New was legendary in the grave, Vito.
Thank you, Fiz.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh, there's so many messages.
I was trying to read everything, you guys.
Thank you so much, though.
This is the best off-kite for me.
I did not sleep until 4 a.m.
every day.
Oh, bruce.
I mean, I guess that means you're having fun.
Come on, Gator.
Thank you so much for the peek.
Thank you for the amazing off-kite.
I was glad I got to meet you and the girls that danced to me
and greet them.
And it felt like it was gone in a second.
Oh, it did, right?
I hope you thought my controller was cool.
It was.
Legends of it was phenomenal.
Buying the VOD to relive it.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Phil, thank you so much for that.
I love the concert, you all did so well, the guests, the
staff of everyone.
Amaze, amaze, amaze!
It made me want to push my comfort zone and just purchase
tickets for Vexpo in September.
It's going to be my first event convention ever!
I'll be attending alone, but I'm excited.
You're not attending alone, Phil!
There will be!
There will be other people!
Other, other, I-boos!
I believe you are an Ace Combat fan.
But, you know.
Missed you.
While you were gone, I just wrapped up directing my
community theater production of the light.
Wait, of Lion King Jr. Junior?
Is...
Simba the White Lion?
Free space.
Thanks for fun, all guys.
Ducky.
Also, Jordan, thank you.
I may have missed every mean, great chance with you, but
it's hard to feel unlucky when I have such a great time.
I let you tell me.
love seeing the choreo for burn on in animation summer you
all look so amazing up there glad to see we're glad to be
your eyeball thank you thank you thank you there's a junior
who's the junior simba junior he's already a baby no cute
the ghost girl i'm glad to let you know it was a great show
and thanks for the meet and greet give it to be straight
boss how bad was my liquid snake impression for real no it
was not that bad i've heard worse i've heard worse
he grows up in the first one yeah but like
yeah I'm definitely glad to be home though I'm glad to be
home and happy to be back on thing here it was it was a time
happy to be home happy to be streaming I don't know I guess
the stress of the the concert got to me I'm way more than I
thought it would.
But now there's just Skyline Serenade in New York for me.
And then I get a little bit of a break.
Oh!
I forgot to tell you guys.
Tomorrow I have an announcement.
Good.
Tomorrow!
Wait, tomorrow.
Hold on.
Wait.
Tomorrow.
Yes.
Tomorrow is stream.
will be an announcement with Ayami Mama.
Um, very cool announcement.
Hmm.
Yes.
I love the concert.
I also love your new outfit.
My new out.
Oh, this one.
Sorry, I was like, my new outfit.
For some reason, I was thinking of a concert outfit.
I was like, huh?
Am I headed to your dead wife montage outfit, which makes
sense because you are a spooky ghost.
Yes.
Rekinday, I thank you so much for the hot guy!
Good to catch a meeting great this time when I had a blast
running around my first ever cosplay of you.
Congrats on the concert, you're so amazing.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Congrats on Legend of New and happy to see you at Offka.
Yeah!
The performances were great, get a lot of rest, I hope you
enjoyed the party-sized Twin Snakes.
Oh, duh, oh, Paige, you literally saved me.
Oh, my gosh.
Part of why Off-Kai was kind of rough was because I like...
I think tech issues would happen.
Things would happen.
Lots of things were going on.
And so food was, like, not a priority.
I had to sign...
Oh, my gosh.
It was 100 can badges, 200 techies.
60 meet and greet things and 80 checkies 80 more checkies
the entire weekend and so
so for me I would be like there's no time to eat I have to
finish the I have to finish signing everything and shirts oh
yes and I also made the shirts you're so right so for me it
was just like oh if i get a chance to eat it will be my
reward and also steiner was like you know my manager he was
running taking care of vicky and febe as well and sometimes
he would be gone taking care of other people and i'm in
signing hell or i'm doing a meet and greet and i'm like i'm
like i'm so i'm so hungry that's not i'm not saying it's his
fault or anything i'm saying things were so busy and so i oh
it was oh it was just i was like i already got out arrogant
her too thank you so loud i was like oh my gosh will i will
i be able to eat today kind of everything um but it's okay
like i said as long as everybody had fun
yums thank you so much for the toto love you and the girls
concert so much i forgot to tell you my name and the mean
great with you but i'll cherish the woman of you saying i
have many ribbons and asking if the ibus were nice in my
first off guy good good good good thank you it was super
nice to say hi the mean great but off guy i said it back
then but you were amazing at legends and new thank Thank you
so much!
Oh, Ark!
Thank you!
Thank you so much for coming to Seahaz.
Thank you, thank you.
I really appreciate it.
I know Vicky was very excited.
I tried to get so much to get your signed button this year.
It was my...
I got it on my last poll!
Me and people around me popped off.
I saw a signer so much at cons the past few months that he
was becoming my...
Don't say that.
I'm not even finishing that sentence.
Hakobi!
Thank you so much for five gifts.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
Whoa, thank you guys for all the super chats.
Hyattens and it was so much fun and the rest of Off-Kai was
just magical.
With so much to do and people to meet, even with no mean,
don't mean great.
I've tried to meet so many people.
Sorry if we couldn't get one.
Watching your stream with my friend would love a hello to my
friend Randy.
Hello, Randy.
Wouldn't mind it.
We won't mind a bit of pizza grease on the check you have
promised.
I wouldn't mind that.
No, Minto, it's always Steiner's fault.
You know what, you're so right.
Look at that, Minto.
Congrats on Legends of Doom.
I had a lot of fun cheering you three on from home.
Yeah, we have the new song.
Dookie, dookie, where?
From your computer.
Straight to your heart.
But it's funny because with that song, the lyrics are a
super silly trio.
Or no.
So wait, no, hold on.
Sorry.
Wait, I can't, I'm confusing, wait.
A super silly three.
I was thinking of old lyrics.
Super silly three.
But we hear a super silly tree.
Oh no, I always hear, whenever I hear the song, I hear
supersonic tree.
Supersonic tree is better than one.
Strawberry, thank you.
Legends of new, five meet, greet, the pedal thank you so
much for always working so hard for iboos so proud of you
minto thank you so much thank you thank you super silly tree
yeah and then hit the pose yeah we do like a silly tree pose
we look like cactars super silly tree super supersonic tree
is better than one okay i can't stop thinking of that part
but hopefully you guys enjoy the new song coming out
Silence, SpongeBob.
I wasn't able to make it out this year, next time for sure,
but I was blown away by Legend of New.
It was awesome to see everyone's hard work on display.
We love you, Minto always will.
Thank you, buddy.
Thank you.
Thank you for your hard work, boss.
You made it such an unforgettable experience for my first
off, Kai.
The eyeballs were just so nice.
I fell right at home sharing my love for you.
JK, I only love lilac.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, what was it?
What was it?
We were hanging out before the show, right?
And we were looking at the flower stand and the names of
people that contributed.
And I can't remember.
It might have been Demon Dice.
It might have been DDK.
She was like, who the heck is Mr. Phantom?
And I was like, oh no.
Who the heck is Mr. Phantom?
Called out by the Demon Dice.
She was so nice.
It was so nice meeting her.
And Asaka was absolute sweetheart.
She...
I was so nervous.
And she, like, grabbed my hand.
Waffle style.
And she was like...
We're gonna do great.
Jessica's so cool.
I, oh my god.
I could not stop gushing about her to everybody.
I was like, listen to her.
Listen to how she sounds.
Listen to the greatest woman ever.
She sounds so amazing.
She's so cool.
She was also very nervous about the whole show.
I think.
Just like making sure it went well.
But she was so awesome.
She was so awesome.
Boost, thank you.
Best birthday person ever.
Happy birthday.
Happy birthday, Legends.
And it was amazing.
I loved your dancing.
Please make sure to eat next time, though.
Thank you.
Every...
I think so often...
Wait, if I go to Discord and I type wasting away...
How many times does it show up?
I would just be like Steiner.
So hungry.
Wasting away.
I was so over and over again.
Steiner, so hungry.
Please bring food.
I'm wasting away.
Wasting away.
I think I said it more in person though.
I feel like, where's the food?
It's in the Uber.
I'm wasting away.
Please bring food.
Afkai Fobo gang, not really since there is a lot of it
stories at Afkai, I've seen it online.
Please no concert spoilers.
I'm halfway into the bot.
I say nothing.
No spoilers?
Lion King Jr. just means it's a kids production.
So it's a regular Lion King, but all the actors are kids.
Oh, I see.
I see.
Minto needs her food to grow tall.
Actually, I got from several people this weekend they were
like i've heard stories about how short you are but i didn't
realize you were so short like what stories are we hearing
who is telling stories about my height
exploding stider in my mind for starving my poor or speaking
of starving i'm kind of hungry right now i think i'm nervous
hold on i don't know No, I am nervous.
I just am.
Hold on.
Brits of Time is.
Brits of time.
Um.
I don't know.
Sometimes I'm not hungry until literally when stream starts.
And I'm like, dang it.
Thank you so much, Brits of Brits of Ten Gifted.
Thank you.
And Ibu!
Thank you for the gift of Thank you.
And thanks for the shirts.
Wicked we.
Um.
I bought a bunch of stuff from a Yami Mama's booth,
including New Minto Book.
She's a great mama hype for the announcement.
VTuber short is a pretty common meme.
But you are a true VTuber among VTubers in that regard.
Maybe.
I don't know.
I'm trying to think of something else stupid.
something else that's stupid that happened is I was waiting
for somebody I don't remember who I was just standing there
and I was facing the doors so it was very bright right the
doors to the outside of the place might have been like the
convention hall I can but it doesn't matter but somebody
walks in and they have their arms stretched out at me as if
they're going in for a hug I couldn't see who it was.
It was so bright, I couldn't see who it was.
And so, they hugged me.
And then they were like, Hello, Mitt.
And I'm like, hi.
Batta mentioned that.
It was Batara.
But I didn't recognize her at all.
And she was like...
Because she had, like, a hat on, and she was kind of
incognito.
I couldn't see a bug.
Actually, I think she was, like, inhabiting her flesh person
or whatever.
And she was like, do you not know who it is?
She was like, you're just hugging random people?
I don't know.
Jesus.
Don't walk at me with your arms out.
I can't say anything.
It's so bright.
I just gave her a hug.
Maybe you know it's me.
I don't know.
I was like, oh, that's sad.
I
don't know.
Confused introvert.
I'm like, oh.
But my, oh, she hugs random women.
I see.
I think I should have known.
I think I should have known I was her because her boobs are
so recognizable at this point.
I think Batara has hugged me more than like my mom.
I thought people were exaggerating, but ignoring me is so
easy because you can literally turn your head up 20 degrees
and she's gone.
What does that mean?
That's how you recognize her?
Yeah, because she's like never wearing a bra.
So it's
really easy to recognize her.
Walking around next off, Kai, with outstretched arms so Mint
will compulsively hug me.
And now!
Some people don't realize how tiny 4'11 until someone that
height is next to them.
But hey, at least you can loom over Hena and Tenma.
And people ask.
actually I got commented on my height more like this this
time this trip than like very much so in recent years so
like I I was telling them I was like I never feel short
until people like point it out and stuff like I don't know
I'm just this is this is just my existence I lived and I
died this way how am I supposed to how How am I supposed
to...
Did I get shorter?
Wait, how?
What do you mean?
I'm like, how else am I supposed to feel?
You know?
Walking into my next meet and greet with the arms
outstretched.
Do I have a shot, Chad?
Hug the TV.
You got this?
You live?
Ghost lived?
I think you need to clear your ears.
I said lived and died!
lived and died clear clear your ears surely I didn't shrink
when I died right so my bad sure I don't maybe I don't think
I shrunk when I died got ectoplasm in the ears you've become
legendary yippee gorgeous.
It's absolutely stunning.
Thank you, Rodrigo.
Hope I can go to next Off-Kai for my birthday.
Oh, it's your birthday in April.
They changed the dates for Off-Kai next year, so...
You meet so many people's weekend just by being there and
being you.
I can think of a few in particular, but that's something
special.
Yeah?
I don't know.
I never feel like I...
I'm just me.
but if anybody is happy to meet me, see me, I felt really
bad about all the technical difficulties that happened
during the weekend.
I felt really like one of my main grades was like two hours
late.
And that's just so...
I was really...
Everything kept exploding.
so uh you know
April of Kai I'm not gonna lie I don't know if I can make it
if you can don't push yourself but if you can that'd be
awesome if not there's always other events do you know
what's wrong with Flamingo I went to her meet-green and she
just shrieked at me what is wrong with her is she broken
don't ask me about her I'm scared of that thing I'm scared
of that thing but um hmm hmm It's a 2-4-4, it was nice
seeing you again.
Very nice of you to let me blab at you during the meet and
greet.
Made the trip 500% worth.
Of course!
Thank you, Curry Ninja.
Thank you for coming to see me.
On the other hand, you were daring with that 3D tech.
Give yourself some credit for going above and beyond.
Maybe.
Really hate when people say you are a child because you are
short.
Like, thanks for rubbing it in.
I don't get called a child I think wait I don't get called a
child I don't think I just get called small
I'm just called small you ever get up ease maybe you get
called yeah I don't get called a child I get called a baby
just get called a baby there's nothing I've skipped child
I'm Benjamin and buttoning back to baby every time there was
a tech issue everyone everyone i was with always worried you
feel badly it was totally not your fault so don't feel badly
thank you for pushing through it for everyone thank you i
still haven't had my big cry yet but i feel like i needed i
was like oh gosh the whole weekend it was quite literally me
being like i'm two seconds from crashing out you guys don't
ask me how i am i will crash out and and i was sharing me
phoebe vicky we're all sharing a room so i wasn't gonna be
like i was there was one night i was like okay i'm gonna go
back to the room and i'm gonna scream and throw everything
but i didn't do that he tried so hard to meet so many of us
and provided so many opportunities to have a special moment
and really does love Aibu.
Yeah, maybe.
I don't know, you'll never hear me say it.
You'll never hear me.
You'll never catch me alive because I'm dead.
You'll never catch me alive.
Saying that.
But yeah, it was overall I still had fun despite everything.
And I'm glad it's over.
I'm glad it's over.
Need to get you in one of those rage rooms.
Give me something to break.
Oh, I hope you can have a smoother experience next time.
Hopefully, we'll see.
The best part was meeting everybody and hanging out with
Phoebe and Vicky.
Yes, yes.
Guys, she's not a child.
She can just go on their rides.
And I can wear children's clothes.
which is awesome because I saw I saw this really awesome
kid's shirt that I was like you guys think it'll fit me and
if I I didn't get it actually but but I I I if I had just
sized up to like a large I could have fit it the children
Eldren's large.
Yippee!
As much as I had fun, I did miss my old painting home.
My Minto streams.
Glad to have you back, Minky.
Glad to be back.
Fish and beyond the user watch without pink!
Locked in for my first off-kite because Steiner kept
dropping hints about it, and it was fantastic!
Missed all the mean grades, but I want an autograph from
Miami, Mama.
Her staff chewed me out for going to Himehina instead of
signing session day one.
Okay, I was so sad, though.
to go to Himehina.
I was like, why does it have to be on the same day?
Why?
But there was no way.
Yeah.
Why couldn't it have been Saturday?
Hmm.
So many concerts.
There were so many concerts.
There were.
One day I'll see Himehina live one day.
I've been a really big fan of them for oh geez so many years
now that like no sad that i couldn't see him but one day
i'll see them live bye boo that's all jpeg dog at off kai
but i was hoping i was able to make you guys smile and
convince you guys please come back of course of course real
though this all kai was amazing first time i went had a
wonderful time with that i woo despite the technical issues
you all put thank you for working so hard for us thank you
thank you i yeah i'm so sorry about all the technical stuff
everything i touch exploded i was like
if there was one point i like i like looked at i like i like
looked at steiner with tears in my eyes and i was like And
before I could even say it, he was just like, you're not
cursed!
He's like, you're not cursed!
Oh.
No worries, explosions are cool, too.
Yeah.
Only, only, only when we explode people, though, and
grandmas.
Yeah.
Yeah, but I hope everybody that went to off guy had a really
really awesome time If you didn't go to off guy, I hope you
had a really really relaxing time I hope you had a nice
weekend And I'm excited to play pal world Wait, let me
double check Okay I played this Last week and I have a kind
of itching for it again This time I want to play With you
guys before we played again everybody maybe that signer's
okay sometimes maybe it's like it's like like out of a
hundred times he is fine like three times three percent fine
only cool people never look at explosions me walking away
from the meet and greets as everything is on fire sunglasses
on.
Even with the issues, it was great to meet you and Densatu
and Offka, it was amazing to see all the eyeballs and
they're happy as a Minto merch.
Hi, Kata, thank you!
It was so awesome, Silly, everybody.
So many, so many Minto, happy, so many Densatsu, happy.
It was so awesome.
And then, and then we were also on the card, the key card
for the for the Hilton.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Punish Steiner, a man denied his compliments.
No, seriously, if you...
The more I see people hang out with him, the more they know
I'm correct.
They say, you are right, Min-to.
But, um...
Yeah, it was really fun being able to room with Denzetsu.
We like...
We would, like, kind of stay up a little bit late, either,
like, in signing trenches or...
Or...
Just, like, I don't know.
We were just having girl talk.
It was so nice.
And afterwards, Vicky and I...
Phoebe unfortunately couldn't come because she has...
She has Otakon this weekend, right?
Oh my gosh.
But Vicky and I, we were able to go to Disneyland.
We kind of, we are splitting our time together.
So basically, Phoebe and Vicky got to go to Australia
together.
Vicky and I got to go to Disney together.
And then Phoebe and I are going to New York together.
So we're like each getting a little bit of each other.
uh at a time yeah you find ways to hang out as much as you
can yeah yeah rotation or rotation hang out rotation vicky
though was so awesome he was so oh my gosh it was so fun
because she was really nervous about some of the rides and
stuff and i would be like no you can do it you will have
much fun.
And she would be like, yeah, I could do it.
Yeah, I could do it.
And then she would get on the ride and she would be like,
that's my favorite ride today.
And then I would be like, okay, now we're going to go on
this other fun ride.
And she would be like, okay, I can do it.
And then she would be like, that's my favorite ride today.
And then there was like, there's like a big
That's like a little more extreme than most Disney rides,
right?
And she was really nervous about it.
And I was like, you can do it.
She was like, yeah, I could do it.
And then afterwards, she was like, that's my favorite ride.
She'd be like, that's my favorite ride.
Emotional supportment.
It was so great.
Expedition Everest or Big Thunder Mountain?
Big Thunder Mountain is actually pretty baby ride.
It's an Incredicoaster in California Adventure.
You expanded her world view.
It was really fun.
It was so, it was so awesome.
I don't know.
We got to go with Dusko.
We got to like just hang out.
Have a good time together.
I don't know.
I was like, after the weekend, I was like, I just want to
hang out with my friends and think about nothing except
rides.
Just think about rides.
And Credit Coaster is the best Disney ride.
It's so fun.
If you ever get to ride it, and if you are into roller
coasters, highly recommend.
Well done to putting together a menu of continually
increasing awesomeness.
I was in the second row for Legends Anu but didn't know any
chance for most of the songs.
Would you ever consider doing a Densetsu collab to go over
some chance of your original song?
Wow, yeah, I think we could.
But also, I mean, you don't have to do the chance unless you
want to.
If you want to learn, I think we can actually let me write
that down.
Densetsu.
I'm talking about mix for our ori song.
If you're just there to vibe, too, that's totally okay.
I'm Victoria Roman, and this is my favorite ride in the
Citadel.
Yeah, I'm...
What was I going to say?
So when we were performing Doki Doki Where, for the first
time, it was very surreal to me that people were able to
pick up on the song and do calls.
We were like, what?
Afterwards, I was like, I was thinking about it.
I was like, that's so awesome.
It was really, really cool.
I was like, wait, this is so cool.
Just had to feel it.
Yeah, exactly.
So it was really good.
It was really good.
Yeah.
Odas are too powerful.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I hope when the song comes out, we're working on making the
music video now.
And it's going to be a funky time.
It's such a fun song.
Yeah.
I was in line waiting for friends for both of your meet and
greet sign.
Do it again.
I was so nervous.
time i wasn't waiting my heart rate my heart rate hit 139
for me and greet that wasn't even mine i see you've trained
as well i ended up instinctually for recopying the end of
night parade to me too actually me too i also had nani and
julie behind so i copied them yeah that'll work that'll work
Yes, yes.
Let me...
Okay, we are playing game today.
I did want to play a game.
Like I said, Afkai was nice.
It was really fun.
But it was a very stressful time.
So I'm like, I'm glad it's over.
I'm glad it's over.
And I'm glad to continue to be back to stream.
Listening to Burn On almost daily and then finally seeing
you and the girls performing live almost made me cry.
Love shouting the calls and response.
Thanks, thank you so much, Minto.
Thank you, like a maniac.
Woo, Jesus.
Thank you so much for the pink.
Going to Legends and New Minto.
It was so fun being able to meet you for the first time ever
cosplaying.
It was so nerve-wracking meeting you that I had to take my
head patch off because of how nervous I was.
Don't be nervous.
De-stress time.
Yeah.
I can't believe I did that.
And afterwards, afterwards, like, we just kind of got.
together and we were all like we did that we did that we did
that legends a new happen we did that so much so much
practicing so much dance practice all the time yeah those
late nights in shibuya at the dance studios yeah You sang
with Asaka.
Wait, I can show you.
I will post this later when I do my big write-up.
If I can show you picture right now.
Hold on.
We took one backstage together.
Wait, where is it?
Oh, wait.
Oh, it's under here.
Boop, boop, boop, boop.
You all did.
that it was amazing yeah glad you think so wait where's the
photo where's the picture
uh what wait wait oh here we go here we go
she's so pretty gosh she's so cute she's so pretty oh so
cool
Well...
Oh, gosh, your face.
Look at her!
She's so pretty!
She was so nice!
Yeah, yeah, so I'll post this later.
She's so cute, right?
She's so nice.
Yeah, I got to go- Oh my gosh, you guys, I got to go to
dinner.
with her.
Wait, the night before, the night before the show, I got to
go to dinner with her.
And, and she was like, I had gotten a pasta dish.
And she was like, she was like, me too.
I really wanted to get that, but I didn't want to get
something too heavy.
Can I try a bite?
And I was like, uh-huh.
Uh-huh.
And so, I got to share my pasta with her.
And then, the end and it was really delicious and she was
like can I try your a little bit of your ice cream and I was
like I'm
glad I'm dead I'm glad I'm dead because i would be dead
again you would never see me i would never see the light of
day again
you won that's our winning ghost that's my freaking ghost
made getting there oh it was so awesome she was so sweet
no everybody should listen to asaka music When, no, not if.
When she comes back, either to the States or to your area,
you should go see her.
She does a crazy good show.
She is so, so good.
Yes, yes.
Love her music.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, wait, how do I...
Wait, join?
I think it's the code.
I need to get the code.
Wait, I need to get the code.
Wait, I need to get the code of our server.
Wait, I'm gonna hide it just in case.
It says that it doesn't show, but I'm scared.
I'm scared.
Okay.
Session not found!
Wait.
Doki bird.
Wait, doki bird.
Wait.
Oh, wait, maybe I joined.
Oh, no, just kidding.
Just kidding.
Oh, I'm glad I hit it.
Wait, I'm glad I hit it.
it because it actually showed.
Okay.
Oh, we're good.
We're good.
Okay.
I clicked the wrong thing.
I did it.
Doki bird.
Doki.
Can you update the game?
Wait.
Okay.
She just needs to re- Oh wait, she, oh, you Chat by Chat Is
saying you just need to Restart the Server Her Her server
are also restarting just now so try again in a minute oh
wait really the
member dragoons the same problem yesterday needs a server
restart doki please doki please please try one more time
yeah yeah hold on okay it doesn't show anything but i'm just
being extra cautious wait
Please?
Well, the reason I wanted to play was not just because I had
a lot of fun last time, but also because I feel like
everyone else had so much more experience with the game.
And I've only played it twice now.
Oh, I'm Scalian.
Thank you.
Mickey, Mickey, Mickey, Mickey, Mickey, Mickey, Mickey,
Mickey.
Minky, Minky, Minky, Minky, Minky, Minky, Minky, Minky,
Minky.
I wasn't able to meet you, but I was seeing you three dance
on stage, best concert ever, meeting you, I was remembering
me that I was just as much to me as getting a meeting greet.
Someone even drew a picture of fishing Minky.
Also, five Ibu's left at my house.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Oh, yeah, I can do that now.
We're saved!
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, Doki just responded.
We're saved!
Yeah, I didn't stream my POV last time.
So, um, now I can get a...
Oh, it's updating, she said.
Now I can get a feel for the game with you guys together.
I'm gonna get boggles tonight.
I love burger.
Burger, burger.
In and out.
Yummy.
What type?
Burger.
Burger, burger.
Let's see if we can join now.
I think so.
Wait.
Okay, what's crazy?
We had a great time.
The concert was amazing.
I'll forever remember it.
I was like, cute girls, damn, my vibes with the cash.
That was cool.
Cool.
Oh, and
maybe I'm going to go to the little ghost's room.
And by the time I'm back, it'll be done.
I promise.
Great performance at Legends of New.
Here's ice cream money to go with that.
Ice cream money!
No!
Wait, I get to get ice cream too!
Try restarting your own game, too.
Oh, you think so.
You think so.
Here, I'll quit.
Wait!
No!
No, no, no, no, no.
We were thinking, though, after the show, we were like, do
we go get something celebratory together?
And we all just went, we just went back to our hotel room
and passed the heck out.
We were like, tired.
Cyberfishy.
It was nice to meet you again.
I hope you have a wonderful off-kind.
Enjoy your love.
Boo-boo's.
I will get them.
give it five to ten minutes she said okay I was told that um
my boxo gifts is like 26 pounds it is it is like this the
the weight of a dog of a bait of a baby it's so heavy
because they're having to ship it to me because I couldn't
take everything with me
26 pounds It's two babies
Wait I think I left my twin snakes No I made it all the way
to the restaurant with my group before I crashed and had to
go back to the hotel Yeah, sorry Oh, sorry that I ran so
late I left my twin snakes candy.
I left them in the car.
No, I left them in the rental car.
No.
My twin snakes.
I was like, I'm gonna go get some twin snakes.
Snack on.
Wait, I probably shouldn't get ice cream because most of my
food this past weekend was just sugar, because it was all
that I had.
I was like, I can't get access to food, so I just got sugar.
Okay, wait.
I go party.
Wait.
Okay.
Oh, server's back up.
Okay, hold on.
By the time I'm back, it will be up.
Wait.
I'll open the game.
Power.
Thank you.
It's coming back.
I got big because I was going to cover the screen, but then
Power World happened again.
Yes.
Okay, one second.
I'll be back.
Oh my god, you guys.
I was pulled.
I pulled the toilet paper and a bug came out.
I pulled the toilet paper and a bug was...
Oh my god.
She met him with the toilet paper!
The toilet paper!
There was a bug hiding in the toilet paper!
What was it?
How did it get in there?
It really did just find another abandoned makeup.
I did!
I mean, no.
I didn't think they would hide in there, though.
What kind of bug?
It was like a...
It was like a... It was like a silverfish.
Scary!
And I freaked out so hard, I think.
It fell on the floor and died.
I was like, ah!
And then it fell and died.
And now let's play Power World.
Bug toilet paper, gotcha.
I've never had anything like that happen to me before in my
afterlife.
That was crazy.
Oh, nice, nice, nice, nice!
Ha ha.
Oh!
Oh, there's me!
We made it back.
Oh, I'm on fire.
Wait, why am I on fire?
Insufficient heat resistance.
There's our beautiful house being made by Nimmy Nightmare.
This guy.
Is all over the...
All over the seeds.
So I'm still trying to learn how to play this game.
points.
Let's enhance my stag.
Sticky-dokie.
This has been the best power world gameplay I've seen in the
last 70 minutes.
It's been 70 minutes.
Don't say that.
Oh, I have three.
I have three.
I've kind of been putting a lot into my stamina.
Stamina and work speed are goaded.
That's what I've been putting into.
We can kind of see a little bit.
you're all like go here
maybe I'll do more stamina stamina is good yeah okay
I'm just learning my game I'm learning how to play I'm
excited what a beautiful day look at my arms I'm really
really buff I'm really stinking buff let me show you guys
where I died wait I have to remember how to play this game
holy cow okay no my weapon is damaged but now i think i can
get uh new things like what is he doing oh this game make me
lag hold on actually i didn't change any of the graphics
because oh this is probably why wait oh this is probably why
because um oh yeah actually we could yeah we don't need
anymore um i didn't i didn't change any graphics because i
wasn't streaming it before minke gains absolutely okay there
we go it still looks good it still looks good repair my
equipment oh it's fine repair you too oh we almost lost you
i need fiber
I can't see beyond 30 FPS anyway.
That's what I always say, but I think I'm rage baiting
everybody.
They think I'm rage baiting, but I'm telling the truth.
I think I need more of the paddle balls, too.
They think I'm rage baiting, but I'm actually just telling
the truth.
You are rage baiting.
Oh my god.
Wait, oh, let's stick.
Speak your truth, girl.
Actually, I have no idea if it's true or not.
I just like to say it because it makes people angry.
Wait, I do have a new build.
Hold on.
Hmm.
Good nap, thank you.
Sorry, I can't super often.
Oh, wait.
Don't do that.
Don't apologize.
Don't know.
Don't ever apologize feeling like you don't super enough.
That's a horrible thing.
Yeah, that is...
No!
No, no, no, no, no.
I just bought a house!
I don't think I could have kept myself together this past
year without your streams and all the lovely eyeballs.
Thanks for all you do and know that your efforts are
appreciated.
Congratulations!
Wait, there's something shiny over here.
What's that?
It's...
I thought it was a rock.
Okay, what am I doing now?
Making powballs.
Can you guys hear the game?
Do I need to turn it up?
Let me know.
How the...
audio is.
Very real.
Oh, I'm hungry.
I'm gonna eat some soup.
Wait, how do I...
How do I...
How do I consume you?
I consume the soup.
Eat the soup.
I'm gonna eat kebab.
Oh, here we go.
I guess you can't eat the soup.
Wait, it says consumable, though.
That's weird.
I can now make a...
Wait, I could make a stone picket.
Wait, I thought I could make a different picket.
I have so many...
Fragments.
Soup is a quest item.
Oh, really?
I loved meeting you at Akai!
I wanted to tell you my inspiration.
Thank you, I cried several times!
Thank you!
Thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Alright.
We got Stinky Grandpa produced cow spheres.
No, I did.
I did that.
Taking it.
That's stolen valor.
You're taking my credit.
I'm just looking at everything in here.
Wait, so, what am I?
Am I using a stone pickaxe now?
Wait, hold on.
Trying to catch up on everything.
Oh, here's the metal pickaxe.
Wait, that's...
Oh, I can't make it because I have no ingots.
You can now make a one-day blinding stew.
The tundra outfits kind of cool.
Is it that we have a lot of...
Hmm.
I don't know.
This is our little farm.
It's very humble and sweet.
And then, let's go do something.
Let's go do some stuff.
What do you have?
Why are you...
You have...
You were holding on to that.
Where'd it go?
Where'd that go?
Hey!
Where'd that... Where?
He was holding on to that fragment.
Shake him a little.
I should have.
Wait, there's some shiny over here.
Is that a ball?
No, heckin' way.
So for anybody getting in, this is my like third time
playing cow world ever.
Where's the money at a There's a chest over here.
I'll take that.
What's in here?
Money, money.
Wait, if I...
Okay, good.
Wait, I can mine some ores here.
Or is this stone?
We got some ore!
Is there anything specific you want to learn about?
Not really.
I'm just... I'm just...
Doing my best.
Try.
Wait, maybe I don't need ore.
It was iron ingot, right?
Or something.
Extra royalties for EMP!
Taufu sounds!
Thank you!
What the heck?
That thing was crazy.
Next time we need to make her underwear for real though.
I'm getting a little embarrassed.
Thank you!
Never?
Whoa!
Oh, big guy, big guy.
You think I could...
Wait.
Why is there a health bar?
I was gonna say, do you think I could take him on by myself,
but...
I don't think by myself.
Unless?
No?
Throw a sphere.
What if I got him, though?
What if it would be really cool?
Doesn't it...
Doesn't the levels scale to your level?
Don't they scale to your level?
We're gonna go exploring.
No.
Not for those guys.
Oh, okay, okay.
What level am I at?
Um...
I'm level...
Oh, oh.
11.
We'll make it there.
Hill of beginnings.
That's my base.
Oh, I did defeat this girl.
I did a really good job.
It said he was like level 20.
We're fine.
We could have done it.
We could have done it, I think.
I'm going to catch more things.
Like, I don't have...
Oh, there's a couple POW balls over here.
Uh, summon POW.
Oh.
Alright.
Go after it, cat.
Yeah.
Oh my god!
Ah!
Don't get me!
Wait, wait, wait.
What's your health like?
Oh.
Hold on.
I think we got him.
Hey, what's bad?
These are nice.
I put on your DMC streams.
I've never watched your work.
and not having to put me in a good mood.
Oh, thank you, Brandon.
I hope you're feeling better now.
My guy is just killing everything.
Yo, yo, yo, we need to chill out.
We need to chill out.
Oh, he's dead in there.
Oh, my gosh.
Hide the evidence.
You could never, you would never know he's in there.
You would never know.
You're probably on command aggressive.
How do I change it?
How do I change you?
He's so cute.
Let's go!
I just started playing.
I think I'm me.
Wait, I kind of want that guy though.
Wait, I want this thing.
Wait, is this...
Oh!
Don't hurt my cat.
Oh my god, wait.
Oh shit.
Ah!
Kill him.
Oh my god.
Wait, I think I can get him now.
I think I could get him.
Much better, thank you!
Yay!
Hi Wi-Fi, our booth!
Hello!
Oh my cat!
My cat!
I need to press...
I need to make you... Oh, you are aggressive.
No, no.
Command.
Peaceful.
Peaceful time.
Wait!
Can't I, though?
Berry Sage.
Can't I ride my dog?
The dog I got?
Defensive.
Defensive is good?
Yeah, defensive.
I want to pet my...
Wait, I can pet the cat.
I can pet the cat.
My baby!
Meow, meow, meow.
Meow, meow.
Put him back to heal him.
Oh, okay.
Uh, hold on.
Let's do...
Oh, I can ride this guy.
hold on come here wait come here come here and then let me
get on you oh i
think i need to make a saddle the water is looking a little
rough you guys it's looking a little geometric i'd say
cute i'm afraid of the water i know i will drown what was
that oh stone It's viscous.
I have no idea where I'm going.
I'm just exploring right now.
We're going up here.
Horse!
Okay, good.
Hmm.
Is there like a...
Oh wait, what's this?
Where are you going?
Uh, dear?
Wait, hold on.
Exploring is good.
Let me check the...
Okay, good.
We are...
Heading to new location.
I've kind of just been following the tutorial.
Hey, Aminto.
Hello, hello.
Wait, these guys are kind of cute.
Vixie.
Exploring is part of the fun.
Yeah.
Cave time.
Is that a cave?
It looks like it should be, but...
There's quite literally nothing there.
there's actually nothing there we need to get iron but I'm
not sure how yet whoa look at the red forest whoa might be
closed it can be a cave
now that doesn't make much sense to me Capri I have one of
these that one ore right there is iron it is I thought it
looked like it, but Hey, what are you doing?
This is mine.
Oh my god, those guys are literally shooting with guns.
It just said ore, though.
Um, should I be...
Oh, should I be concerned?
Yeah.
these wait they have a whole base right there wait a second
they've they've they have wait what's this they haven't
captured they're they're doing something what's this thing
past always journal are we about to attack are we about to
take over this place go kick their butts
I think a deer is a good guy to use.
I'm gonna rescue this guy.
How can I do that?
Oh, they're long gone.
Who are you?
I'm releasing you, pal.
Daisy!
Yippee!
They'll never know.
I don't even know where they are.
can i rob them of all their worth oh what
is he doing oh oh oh what's he doing you got one really
early are they good they're kind of broke no way the
ground is confused no everybody's confused Nobody knows what
you're doing, man.
Oh my god.
Jax, thank you so much for the...
Ray, hello.
Um, anyway.
We're just gonna ignore that guy.
They quite literally have nothing here.
What?
What does this mean?
Oh, is this one of those jumping things?
Oh, what a strange location.
Now, how can I enslave the man?
Raymac, thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
How can I enslave him?
Can't I steal the people?
Oh, nice.
Oh, okay.
Get him in the butt.
He died fast, yeah.
Stupid head.
Okay.
Nice.
Rob them.
Rob them of all they're worth.
Yeah.
Is there another guy?
Oh, shoot.
Wait, hold on.
Oh, no.
I was going to pal-sphere him.
Dang it.
My horse is really strong.
Oh, dear.
Yep.
Nice.
Let's go this way.
There are more of them.
Yeah, we're too OP.
We'll get them next time.
This place is pretty, though.
I'm excited.
Go into the red.
I'm not excited to go into the red, I mean.
Like, oh, game is lagging.
You look like Ashitaka from Mononoke.
Maybe a little.
Oh.
What did he do that?
What is that over there?
Whoa, there's so much to explore.
Everything is new to me.
I played PAL World first time.
Oh, geez.
I don't even remember how long ago.
A couple years ago.
And then...
Oh, I'm almost to my max limit with...
We gotta find a place to offload.
Ninkies!
I found a fast travel place.
But then I played it for the second time ever, like, last
week.
So everything is new to me.
And it's very exciting.
Oh, there's another guy!
No, no, I have a deer right here.
If I look at the map...
Oh, is this?
Yes.
You need to marker that.
marker marker no okay is it which way could it be having a
cat of a pink cat in your party increases your carrying
capacity by hundred pounds or handy early game doesn't have
to be out just in your party oh okay Mimi good to know I
guess I'll go get one eventually is that a coconut oh no
it's an egg
Um...
I don't even know who's in my party.
My Kaepernie is dead!
How do I heal you?
How do I heal him?
There you go.
You're kind, you're kind.
Wait.
It's a little bit this way.
Alright.
Uh...
Are you guys still here?
Wait.
Still a little bit more.
A little bit more.
I'm hungry!
Gotta put him back in the pal box.
Oh, so just having him in my inventory is not enough.
Oh, that guy looks aggressive over there maybe.
Hmm.
This is purple.
Is it safe?
Is it safe, dear?
Wait, how do I...
Oh, those are seeds.
I'm trying to eat seeds.
Oh, mushroom?
Oh, good, good.
Okay, I'm full.
It's a secret.
Oh, I opened it.
Yippee!
Okay, we're still going...
Oh, it's a little this way.
But what's...
There's...
From far away, this looked like a plane wreckage.
But it is some sort of wreckage.
Hold to get.
Whoa!
Wait, wait, wait!
No!
Dear, you were too powerful!
Oh, man.
Too heavy.
Wait, is that it over there?
I think we found it.
Oh.
Ruby.
Wait, I want that guy.
Alright, deer.
Deer, I want that thing.
Deer.
You can always recall.
Yeah, I probably need to learn to do that.
When I can.
Let's grab some of this more stuff, even though I'm getting
weighed down.
But leather seems kind of handy to have.
Alright.
Fast travel.
Unlock.
Yippee!
Okay.
Alright, let's go home.
To base.
And then.
Put some stuff down.
Deer doesn't want any new friends.
The POW box.
I don't even know what that looks like.
I don't even know what that is.
Is this my pal box?
Oh, it is, it is.
Oh, yes!
Let's, let's, let's, uh...
Level 5.
My deer is so powerful.
The higher wolf is only level 5.
My lamb ball is level 10.
Alright, put some stuff away.
Okay, everything is, uh...
I have, I have literal bullets.
I have, what the heck?
Okay, hold on.
My technology tree.
I want the egg incubator because I have an egg.
I have an egg.
Probably because he was in your party against the boss.
Oh, that's probably it.
You're right.
You can ride the wolf.
Yeah, I was thinking.
Wait, wait.
harness can I get the one for well I'll just unlock it
anyway because I can get it on I can make one house plant
berry plantation sand this is terrifying that we're like
World War one here in the trenches hmm hot springs
Oh, I want the pelt armor.
Yeah, see, how do I make ingots?
Because I have ore, but I have no ingots.
Crazy tech tree.
Wait, I can ride my fox sparks too!
That's huge, that's huge.
Furnace.
Alright, thanks, guys.
I'm using you for everything.
Wait, where could a furnace be?
Can I even...
A grappling gun?
Oh, primitive furnace.
I already have it.
Wait, we might have it...
Made already.
Maybe not.
What is this?
Applied?
Wait.
I don't think so.
Maybe not.
Okay, hold on.
I want...
Oh, build, hold on.
This.
There we go.
I'm getting used to it.
I'm remembering.
Let's put it...
In the house.
I can set an egg!
Wait.
This guy.
Oh!
I'm going to do it!
I'm going to become...
I'm going to become a mom.
If you find a pal with the mercy trait, they won't kill
anything.
Just reduce it to one.
This really helps in capturing new pals.
There's also a ring that does the same for you for your
damage.
Wait, it's six hours!
Okay, guys.
This is going to be a crazy long stream.
Alright, let's build our thing now.
I'm just going to build it here.
Oh, there we go.
I'm building, I'm building, I'm building.
Are you anybody, anyone want to come help me with this?
Nope.
Just me.
Place a pal in the base pal slot of your pal box that will
help.
Oh, yeah.
This is fine.
I think you can speed it up with a fire, pal.
Oh.
They're eeping.
Yay!
All right.
Let's make some ingots.
Yeah.
I can make a ton.
Holy cow.
I can make a ton of ingots.
Let's make 50.
I need a fire, pal.
I guess I could put in fox, fox, barks.
We don't need two waters.
Don't go to sleep!
Okay, we're going to sleep.
Oh, it just Just summon him.
Oh, okay.
Ah.
Good night.
Just throw from your party.
This guy is so cool.
He's so cute.
Hungry.
Who's hungry?
I have seeds.
Who wants them?
All right.
Yeah!
Yes!
More!
Wow.
least take a while um let me wait maybe i can take out
another one uh yeah more wait no no you're supposed to be
doing it together never mind only one at a time i guess this
is fine i have a single ingot yes yes yes yes it's okay it's
a primitive it's a primitive one we'll get better ones in
the future trust trust trust Trust, trust.
And I can make the three shot bow.
Wait, did I not make that before?
Wait, what am I using?
Old bow.
No one wants that.
Three shot bow.
Sure could use some help over here.
Work your way to gun.
Oh my gosh.
Come on, man.
You're not even helping.
You're just dancing.
Come on.
I need you to put in the work, buddy.
Let's engineer.
Yep.
And...
Good.
Nice.
All right.
Now, I have the...
The better pickaxe unlocked.
the metal one oh it's because I need the 15 ingots okay
we're gonna be able to for sure we're gonna be able to for
sure now how do I make stop making that sound I don't like
it this wooden chest holds nothing you know how do I make it
hold everything you know need a metal chest I don't think I
can make that yet
Oh, I'm on fire.
I'm hot for some reason.
More chests.
You're so right.
Let's just build some more.
Storage.
I like how nothing is...
Nothing is put in a good way.
kind of sprawled out oh oh i'm on i'm fought i'm on fire oh
yeah oh yeah all right let's put some cloth i have an
electric organ maybe someone will want to use that i'm still
hot my key training manual there's a tiny amount of xp when
read by a pal oh neat little kinship peach
What was that?
I think I just took a ton of beans.
Oh, so many berries.
Alright, nice.
So much fiber.
I'm all beans.
Let's put my...
No.
I lied.
Actually, I want to hold on to that.
Can I, like, just get rid of this?
Simple bait.
I don't know how much I have now.
The thing is, is it's not even showing up.
The pickaxe, the metal one.
I have enough stuff for it.
I have to make a better...
Oh, the high quality workbench is what I need.
Okay, okay, all right, we need to order of operations then.
Got it.
Technology, I need to be able to make nails.
All right, let's make some nails.
Like, a lot of them, a lot of them.
Hello, hello, hello, thank you.
All right, all right, great.
Can I get rid of some of these workbunches?
We have the technology, yes, yes.
Yes we do, we do, we do.
A lot of ore needed at this stage, okay.
Didn't somebody, nobody make it high quality?
I don't think so, I have no idea to be honest.
Nice, thank you.
None of these look high quality to me.
They all look stinko.
B then C.
Disassembly mode.
Okay.
Yes.
Paint mode.
Build mode.
Oh, cool.
Okay.
Wait, oh, wait.
Infrast- no.
Uh, what is this?
Global POW box!
Very, very interesting.
No, production.
High quality.
What is that guy doing over there?
He's just like...
Into the earth.
Nice!
Alright.
We'll grab these.
Run over here again.
Grab this.
Still stone.
Oh, here we go.
Yes.
Oh, yes, yes.
We'll soon be able to...
Alright, cool.
He's off to the spit and greet.
Spreading his code!
When building, you can also snap to things.
Oh, really?
Okay.
I don't want to, like, you know...
Today is not about cleaning up so much as it is just
learning the game.
You know what I mean?
So I'm gonna also...
We're gonna do this where I put this guy in.
It originally was...
Actually, I have no idea.
You.
It's a you now.
It's all you.
You.
I don't remember who it was before.
Hmm, we're learning.
We're learning.
Do I have enough to make another pickaxe now?
Not quite.
Just one more.
It's going to get crowded.
Start building vertically.
Is there anything else?
I guess I gotta just level up to get more stuff.
I'm trying to save my tech points for that reason a little
bit.
what are what are you doing
I think it's kind of crazy you can get hot and take damage
from your own like fires this is kind of kind of crazy um oh
the seeds that's what I was gonna put in here yeah combine
those hot springs might might be nice to keep your guys
happy okay we can do a hot springs I'm guessing I build that
Aquatic PAL fluids.
Now you think if they could come up with a better way to...
To...
Oh, a saddle!
That's right!
Um...
I can make two different...
Wait, this is all of it.
No?
Yeah.
Where's my saddle?
I unlocked it.
How do I make...
Oh, I still need fiber, but...
PAL juice.
Other bench?
This one?
Aha!
Harness for holding fox barks.
Wait, so it's not riding him?
Activate his partner skill to hold fox barks and attack
using it as a flamethrower.
Wait, that's hardcore.
Wait, that's kind of insane.
My pals are marinating in the aquatic fluids.
I don't want to think about it like that.
I really don't.
I don't want to think about I like that.
Not at all.
Metal pickaxe.
Yeah, we'll cut some trees for five or then we'll be able to
ride my dog.
That's good.
So...
How?
Well, oh, I forgot to acquire it.
How do I get rid of it?
Oh, discard.
Okay.
Come here.
Come here, tree.
Fiber.
Give me fiber.
Give me more fiber.
Give me the most fiber.
Discard the thing that was literally right in my face.
But everybody knows the beat-tippers can't read.
Shiny.
Is that what that is?
What's the shiny?
I hear it.
How do you read chat?
Vibes.
All vibes.
Bottom right of the cliff.
It's like definitely coming from this way.
Oh, I see him!
I see him!
Wait, okay, hold on.
Maybe I can take him on myself.
Huh.
Wait, I'm scared.
No, no, no, no.
Peaceful.
Maybe now?
Maybe?
I weighed down by my pal is too heavy.
We got him!
First try!
Wait!
Now I can make this guy saddle!
Even better, even better, even better, even better!
Meat cleaver!
Let's go.
Paparai.
I like the stickies guy in his tail.
We got a big cat.
Let's go.
How do I get back home this way?
How did I get too heavy?
It's my arms.
My arms made me too heavy.
So true.
Let's see.
What was I building?
I remember I made from leather.
It's warmth and defense as well.
Oh, wait.
Okay, hang on.
A flyer.
Oh, sorry.
That guy scared me.
Saddle, yes.
Yes, yes, yes.
But I think we can take out this guy now.
And now we can put in my shiny.
There.
Now I can be...
Now I will have more weight, right?
Okay.
Oh, my stat points too.
Let's do...
Work speed.
Yes, my weight went up.
That's cool.
Shiny cat.
Saddle, saddle, saddle.
What?
Knife for butcher.
We're eating pals.
That's...
Eating a pal is not cannibalism.
I think I'm a human in this game.
You have to eat to survive.
It says eaten pals will not come back.
Not technically cannibalism yet.
Can I eat the thugs?
The bandits.
Will I get brain worms?
Can't get any more brain worms than I already have, though.
I don't think true pals eat pals.
Matarar is such a curse name You already have brain worms
That's what I'm saying That's what I'm saying Alright now I
make this saddle And then I give it to my deer And we'll be
set, baby Nice, that took a while Okay, how do I What is
this?
Oh, ancient civilization parts Precious claw My pre...
Is it already on him?
Oh No.
Oh, oh, come back!
Wait, come back!
Oh, you're logging, that's what you're doing.
No, I'm pressing F to ride.
There we go.
Yay!
Oh, power shot.
F will summon them.
Oh, okay, I had no idea.
Yeah!
Wait, this is awesome!
My little guy is following me around.
I can't really put him away.
Is that fine?
Oops.
My bad.
Dismound.
How do I...
I'm actually trying.
This guy.
It's an ability.
How is it?
This extra non-lethal damage.
Really?
Wait!
She's so cute though.
daisy daisy daisy let's go back into the defensive mode and
let's go back oh nice
let's go uh
oh wait oh where'd that come from
i have to does this let me fast travel this thing right here
i stream buffer but by consensus one hour 58 cannibalism art
what where no this is enhancing powers i think i have to go
down here right get back to the fast travel my evil job is
taking me away but before i go i want to say the concert was
absolute thank you to have a long drive back home i had
plenty of time to reminisce and i found myself tearing up
yeah don't tear up you'll make me tear up you can fast
travel from your base i can't you can tp from any okay okay
good to know i had no idea see this is what would i do
without you guys what would i do without you guys wait what
is this what's that now look at your map
Hum?
What was that?
What was it?
Hum?
No, come here.
It was up here, right?
Whoa, Lion King!
Oh, it's a Pen King!
Oh, thank goodness it's not Pen Island.
That would be bad.
I'm sure he's out for the VOD on campus.
Wait, there we go.
Wait, where is he?
Wait, what's that?
Is that a person?
Are you a friend?
Cautious officer.
Can I talk to you?
Oh.
Talk.
Cannot do all right.
Hello.
See that huge structure towering over the ocean?
That's a syndicate oil rig.
It's a dangerous place, so make sure to stay away from it.
Mother base?
Wait, I can catch him?
Come on, ball!
Aw, man.
Wait, what's that green thing over there?
There's also...
This.
Open.
Nice.
Can we...
What's that over there?
Oh!
Wait, there's glowing guys, too!
Oh.
What is that?
Wait, guys, what is that?
Need a fishing rod.
Does that require one too?
Oh.
My...
My pal sounds like it's taking a leak.
also need a hat okay i don't know what that means that's
fine we're just exploring where's the pen king the pen king
of pen island
we lost him that's okay when you gotta go you gotta go He is
but an animal.
I look so cool riding this thing.
Look at me.
Go up the stairs by the teleport.
Oh, is that where he was?
Oh, okay.
Nobody tell Minto using the butcher knife on the chicken pal
gives her extra technology points.
The chicken who?
Wait, there's another gloomy thing.
What does that mean?
What did I do?
What?
Who?
I hear something dropping.
Somewhere there.
Oh dear.
We gotta go.
Go get it.
I'm going.
Wait, there's something up there too.
Gosh, there's so much stuff everywhere.
Alright, hold on.
Bread.
Let's get this bread.
Alright, hold on.
Alright.
Don't die, please.
Don't fall into the water and die.
Gosh, wait.
Guys.
Deer.
Uh, deer?
Oh, okay, we're fine.
We're fine.
Get the bread.
Okay, we're fine.
All right, we're fine.
We're fine.
We can make this.
Deer?
You'll have to teleport, man.
Nice, nice, nice.
Wow, some good powballs.
Okay.
Um, I don't think getting up there is possible.
Yep.
Okay.
All right.
We'll make it to the second ledge here.
Okay.
Nice.
Third ledge.
All right.
Yes.
This is why we invest in stamina.
All right.
Nice.
Oh, there's a loop moon.
I don't know what that means.
Yep.
Wait, we might be able to make this as a ledge.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, yes.
No, it was a ledge.
It was a ledge!
No!
That was a ledge.
That should have given me.
All right, hold on.
We'll call it a different way.
Does this...
I hope the stuff doesn't just despawn eventually.
That would be sad.
Uh-oh.
Come on.
You can make it.
Yep.
I'm gonna die.
I'm gonna die
My deer is also trying We're all trying
Grappling gun Okay Let it reset I don't know if I can make
this guys It seems pretty tough I'm gonna die if I drop one
more time I'm gonna die if I drop again.
I can't risk it.
I have to find another way up.
A bridge.
What level am I at?
I think like 12.
Okay, hold on.
I think I was able to climb up this.
Let's go.
Oh, my dear.
Oh, dear.
Alright, come on.
Alright.
Whoa.
Oh, okay.
Nice.
All right, run this way.
He'll make it.
Oh, dear.
Oh, gosh.
It's scary.
I got him.
I need to know what that shiny is.
Or I won't be able to sleep tonight.
There's someone guarding the bridge.
Wait, is this somebody's house?
Legend loving researcher Get off Oh, holy you there This is
a bit sudden, but have you heard the old legends of the
legendary pals said to roam these parts?
I've been studying them for many long years now, but not
once have I laid eyes on one It's a den she?
Not even a glimpse, so I was wondering, would you be willing
to search for them in my stead?
Steed?
Stead?
they used to be see rumor has it that there's at least one
legendary pal in each of these places mount obsidian to the
west the astral mountains to the north the des desiccated
dunes out the east and the remote land folks called feybreak
see that tall jagged rock over there if you climb up to the
top you could get a good view if you managed to find one of
those legendary pals would you be kind enough to let an old
man see it with his own eyes i'll be waiting friend
someone's making a lot of noise in here oh this your bird
let's go what is this thing catress cute I need you oh wait
power shot is that a homing ouch guys I think we're screwed
wait um Wait, we're so screwed.
Uh...
Go and do damage, please.
We might need to run.
We might need to get out of here.
Old man!
I need your help!
I'm doing no damage.
Uh, let's go.
We're getting out of here.
Just run.
Just go.
Just go!
Where's my guy?
My horse.
No.
Is it gonna be mad at me again?
Oh, it was level 26.
I didn't even notice.
I just went.
I just went for it.
You think it's gonna be mad at me again?
La la la.
You don't know me.
The staring.
La la la.
They've never met me before in your entire life.
My haunts is dead.
Try to use the yellow ball.
We could try.
Hold on.
I'm going over here first.
How do I switch balls?
I see.
Gigosphere.
It's this thing.
Lamb ball effigy.
Two.
Awesome.
Thank you, guys.
I actually figured it out all on my own, though.
I saw the little thing behind me.
It's for the base, yeah.
I only have one.
Is it gonna get mad at me?
Don't get mad at me.
Okay, here we go.
Ouch!
We're fine.
Everything's fine.
Oh, finally, something that's afraid of me.
What?
No!
You were supposed to be afraid of me!
Oh, shoot.
Guys, is this all over?
Um, I didn't touch you!
Goodbye, cruel world.
Oh, shoot, my stamina.
We're fine.
It's fine.
We made it, I think.
I don't know where I am.
Okay, we're fine.
Yep.
He took some damage.
My cat's going for it.
Oh, no.
My cat's not out.
Yep.
Oh, come on.
Come on.
Just hug the wall, hug the wall, hug the wall, hug the wall.
Hippocrate Hill.
Oh, that's right, we were trying to find the stuff that
fell.
I forgot.
I forgot about that.
Let's keep finding it.
We can find it.
No problem.
I'll have a snack.
Oh dear.
Let's see.
We need to get back up here though.
That's sidetracked.
Just a tad.
I wanted that cute cat.
And then I got really sidetracked when this attacked me.
We're gonna go find this stuff.
We're gonna find this stuff.
This is one.
Wait.
Who's that?
Another egg!
Yoink.
Nice.
Yeah, there we go.
Alright.
back to that tower there's an upgrade and here if
I die it will be your fault Alan I'm
hacking oh send power from the source through all the panels
to the core panel to unlock the door send the power from the
source to all the panels oh I get it wait how do I undo or
reset Like that?
Oh, do I have to fill the whole thing?
Ah, okay.
Go at it.
Dog coin.
Sword schematic.
Cool.
Something shimmery shiny right there.
Would it be wood?
Leather.
All right, let's see if we can find an easy way up.
We're fine.
Yeah.
Hmm.
The bird looks like it'll kill me.
All right.
Okay, nice, nice.
Here's another ledge.
Please, please.
Okay.
Wait, wait, wait.
Here we go.
When falling, you can remove the glider to save some stamina
and pull it out before you hit the ground.
Good to know.
Oh.
Hmm.
There's a guy laying there.
Huh.
Just chilling?
TP spot, yeah.
I am the chief judge of the World Pal Exhibition.
That's what it looked like.
I came to this region to see Muffley, but it got away.
I will give you the honor of showing me Muffley.
You may thank me later.
Miffy?
Yay!
All right.
Please don't kill me.
I just want that guy.
Okay, nice.
All right, it's like somewhere over here, I think.
Opposite way.
Is it over here?
Somewhere over.
Wait, is that it?
No, that's a big guy.
Eh?
I'm getting all...
Wait, okay, it's...
It's...
East.
Oh, on the compass.
You're so right.
I'm like trying.
I can't.
Wow, this place is or central.
Holy cow.
Trying to like.
I don't even know what it looks like.
Over this way.
Weast.
Oh, he's guarding it.
No.
They're level 18!
No!
What are we gonna do?
Let's just show you what?
Oh.
Sneak.
How do I sneak?
Oh my god.
What's happening to him?
I'm gonna catch him.
Oh.
We got this guy.
Easy peasy.
Oh, he's...
He's hacking?
Yeah!
Yeah, Robin the Valley's worth.
Ouch!
Those moves!
Is there a third of the guy?
No, I think it's just the two.
Can I catch him now?
Wait, maybe now?
No, he's dead.
He's dead.
We did it!
We could do it!
Whoa, hypersphere, metal helm schematic.
Take all, take it all, take it all.
Need the silver key.
Hey, why can't I lockpick?
They're feeding off of his body!
His
body!
This game is incredible!
reading him!
Wait, for real though, they just devoured that guy.
I got a pal soul.
There's more over here, actually.
I got something about the circle of life, huh?
A bird's gonna live, too.
That was craziness.
Are you so high level that I can't take you?
I'd rather not.
I think I'm actually running out of bows or arrows, I mean.
Wait, is that another fast travel thing?
This game is so glitchy, it's hilarious.
Yes, it is, it is, it is.
Uh, hacking?
Find the correct position.
Oh, locate a vulnerable spot.
Oh, no!
Wait, I didn't...
Wait, you can try as many times as needed.
Wait.
Oh, interesting.
Okay.
I'm an absolute hacker.
Life pendant schematic of unused stat points.
Let's see.
Let's enhance my...
Maybe my weight.
If you ate that bird, you'd get an MGS3 achievement.
It's so true.
Hacker voice.
My regular voice is my hacker voice, actually.
I always be hacking.
We increase my gains.
I'll increase my gains.
Gale Claw.
Those things are scary.
Do not mess with them.
If I die, they'll literally eat my body.
Wait!
Is that the muffly?
That the guy was like, please show me a muffly.
Show me a muffly.
Oh shoot, I think I'm out.
Ouch!
Oh my goodness.
Wait, I don't even know which one I was Oh, shoot.
I think I'm out of arrows.
Wait, I so died.
No!
I didn't get...
It's okay.
We'll respawn close.
Yeah, we gotta revive my horse.
You're so right.
My pals, I dropped everything.
Wait, where did I die?
Screw you, man.
You suck.
You killed me.
off you guys can really see my arms now I'm starting a class
action lawsuit against the Ghostbusters are you in for what
what did they do you guys can really see my outfit now
muscle veto wait they're gonna eat my body no I saw it
happen and now it's happen to me oh man can i open this nice
my stuff
oh a soul i don't know what these do but i'm grabbing them
all right let's just go over to there and uh
wait death chest oh no i'm out of space well that I can go
in there.
Oh, what?
Huh?
Press X?
Oh, that's so strange.
Funny, funny mechanic.
Just take all.
Alright, we'll get the...
Some more bullets.
I think actually this guy is...
Wait.
Yeah, well, we'll stick with Fox Sparks because...
I think he's technically his higher level, so...
Bullets, yes.
A gobfin.
Gobfin's turf!
I would have never guessed.
Let's go heal my horse.
Hey, what's that right there?
It looks like a summoning thing.
That's kind of...
Bounty Intel dealer.
It's kind of nice that there's like always some kind of
guise around the fast travel it seems.
Gobfins are aggressive.
They look at it.
Look at them.
Go home.
We're fine.
I was in gobfin territory, right?
Let's see, um, put my deer in there.
Feel better, feel better, buddy.
Feel better, buddy.
Okay.
The dire wolf is fast.
So is my deer.
Oh, I need someone to do these ingots.
Uh, let's put you back in here.
For now.
How?
Oh, let's do the offering.
It's over here, no?
Um...
There.
Yes, satiate...
Satiate the duration.
Okay, cool.
Check the egg.
You're right, you're right!
Our egg, our egg, our egg!
No, wait, our egg was like six hours.
Our egg is a long time from now.
Oh!
How long have I been playing this game for?
Not that long.
Wait, what just happened?
How did that happen?
Put fires near the incubator.
But this is...
But... But... But...
We'll catch the house on fire, no?
How did the time go up?
Seems a little hot.
Wait.
Seems very comfortable.
I'm being lied to.
Told poor advice.
Metal helm.
A helm made of metal.
No kidding.
A reliable piece of armor that protects your head.
And all the thoughts within.
Also, I got like this life pendant.
I need bone.
Wait, I can make this.
I can make this.
raises health.
Okay, let's go get some ingot.
Let's go get some more ore.
There was some over here, I think.
Must protect my thoughts.
Oh, here's some.
Here's some.
Nice.
Alright.
I'll put it in.
Last pouring.
Thank you so much for the 10 gifted.
Wait, how do I put in more?
Maybe here?
Uh, no.
Oh yes.
But...
Cancel it and put it in again?
Okay.
Select recipe.
Oh, charcoal!
Interesting.
Starch production?
Alright, there we go.
That actually, well, I have nine right now, and I needed how
much?
I needed 25.
Okay, 25.
Where do I get bone?
Where do you get bone from?
I wish it would tell you.
Can you shut up?
What are you doing?
So I would need 50.
Okay.
Let's go get some more.
more fun
game and stream thanks soap thanks for the super chat wolves
give bones okay okay i believe there was right now there's
some ore close by
grab you yeah big chunk oh wait let me give my stamina back
up okay we're good nice nice
Don't worry about it.
It's more gains.
The more weight I carry.
This is stronger my arms will be.
Don't worry about it.
Yeah, this is all according to Kekaku.
Remember Ibu is we must wear helmets to pressure press press
press protect your thoughts Oh my god guys, I'm really slow.
Don't worry.
I've I'm
Okay, we'll make it back
this is all because i missed the leg day oh my gosh i
invested everything in the arms now everybody don't look
everybody's gonna look at me and laugh that guy's gonna turn
around and laugh at me oh that guy so embarrassing this is
so don't look don't look
But I have now...
70 ore!
We're so good.
We're so in.
Oblivion looting trained you for this.
So true!
How the Amazon bag is just moving.
The walk of shame.
No, the house is right there.
Home is just right there.
Just right there.
Actually, let's do this.
Oh.
Not one.
Half.
Take half.
Oh, shift.
Did I drop it?
Okay, we'll be back.
We'll be back.
Do we have to stand and walk on your own?
Everything will fall out!
Like, they would...
Like I'm being...
Like I'm being bullied!
Give me your lunch money, kid.
Okay, cancel.
And redo.
No, take that.
Okay, redo.
honestly i don't even need to do anymore we'll grab the orb
the ore and then i said i called it the orb my bad we'll
grab the ore and then uh oh there it is and then anybody
else can use it wait you're trying to get my attention or
something oh they just they just follow because I went on
the cars ride at Disney which is so fun by the way I watched
the movie cars for the first time recently and I want to say
I think I legitimately press CNX at chess and it will auto
stuff no way really okay awesome I think that movie is
terrifying legitimately this is so scary best mechanic open
inventory and R2 stack items.
You guys are helping me so much.
Thank you.
Wait, not my bone.
Yeah, whatever.
Oh, I thought that was a sword.
That is a really sword-looking...
What piece of wood, though?
Wait, didn't we get the schematic to make a sword?
Oh, not that.
I got the spear.
Here, a sword!
A wooden board.
Hey, wake up!
You're not allowed to sleep.
Wait, you guys- Oh, it's a little cold.
Oh, no, wait, because it's daytime now, right?
She fell in love with Doc.
It's over.
How did you know?
Wait, how did you know that I fell in love with Doc Hudson?
Wait, how did you know?
How did you know that?
Wait, how did you know that I- that Doc was my favorite
character.
Wait, how did you know that?
Wait, I'm scared.
How did you know that?
Doc's the best character.
Many else have fallen.
No, I watched cars for the first time.
The Miadas were flashing their high beams, you guys.
And then...
There
were many things that just made me be like, what does this
imply?
Raiders, wait, who raided me?
Thank you, thank you.
Thanks for the gift that you guys, thank you so much.
Nyaru, thank you, thank you, thank you.
I'm learning things I didn't want to know.
Me too.
Oh, I'm climbing the house, like, okay.
I'm a...
Okay, seems very comfortable.
Good, good, good.
We're comfortable.
All right, we're going to make this pendant, this helm.
I need bone.
Let's go get some bone.
All right.
Let's go find a wolf, I guess.
I'm actually hungry too, though.
Anybody else hungry?
Wait, let's check on my gun.
I wish I could raise my I wish I could have more you know oh
he's all better yippee oh no he's not but it shows him all
but oh he's still growing oh just a little bit more
don't forget to oh make arrows yes thank you Yes.
Let's make arrows while...
50?
I need a level up.
You can hold more.
I need a level up, baby.
You can use the wolf as a mount.
He's faster.
I like him, my dear.
I like him.
Are you helping me or are you just...
You're not even helping me.
It's like when someone says something dumb on Twitter
without a checkmark.
for the love of the game.
You're just...
You're not even helping me.
You're not doing anything.
Wait, did I just make 510 arrows on accident?
Wait, did I make so many on accident?
I thought I made 50.
You can cancel.
I feel committed now.
No, I should cancel.
Okay, stop at 250.
Oh.
cancel let's just cancel cancel the work okay oh i have too
much stuff again is it all my arrows hey are you done you're
not you're not finished where are you what do you think you
get a lunch break or something where are you time to make
another chest wait hold on wait there's my score swords
schematic let's put it in here wait it's like purple is it
good Okay, hold on.
I'm trying to think of what I want to do here.
No breaks on Minto's watch.
Yeah.
None.
There's four levels, and that's a level three.
Oh, wow.
That's pretty good.
Epic sword.
Maybe I should work on making that first, then.
Okay, hold on.
I'll put the ore away.
yeah that's right keep working keep working buddy keep
working my sword requires board wooden board
is that something that i've unlocked do i know how to make
wood or is that under build i don't think it would be under
build No, I need to be level 15!
No!
A crossbow.
Wait a second, though.
Cooler box.
Small food vault.
Assign an ice pal to help prevent food store inside from
spoiling.
Very cool.
Oh, metal chest.
Metal chest!
Oh, my ingot.
No
breaks, no breaks.
I'm guessing the crossbow is better than the...
The bow that I have right now?
Not always.
Interesting.
Okay, we're gonna put more ingots in.
I am once again heavy.
Canceled.
Okay, nice.
It needs different arrows.
Takes longer to reload.
Gotcha.
So pros and cons.
Pros and cons.
Anybody else hungry?
Okay, my guy's back to normal.
Let's go.
Yeah.
More, more, more.
Alright.
I guess we can put away some oil.
Oh, this thing about the...
Oh.
It's consumable.
It's legendary.
What is this for?
Soft.
I'm used to make clothing.
Cool.
Oh, same arrows?
Oh, okay, cool.
Don't drink the yellow potion.
It gives permanent...
Oh, drink the yellow potion.
Ineffective when used by POWs.
Extremely valuable potion that permanently...
That's huge!
Oh, just kidding.
Yum yum yum yum Oh my gosh The game is a little overwhelming
Sometimes you know With how much there Hello there you go
How much there is to manage Um I want to place this guy in
the incubator I feel like it says it's an uncommon egg
Currently we have a common pal in here Wait I could No I
shouldn't I shouldn't.
I shouldn't.
I'll keep him in here, though.
Someone else can incubate him.
Okay.
Good job.
Just leaving your wood on the ground.
How many pal spheres?
Okay, I have 15.
Let's make a few more.
Wait.
Can I not make spheres with the high quality work, bitch?
Wait, do I need a...
Do I need a rinky-dink workbench to make a sphere?
Sphere workbench.
You need a sphere workbench.
I can't believe I can't make... Oh, there's the crossbow.
I can't believe I can't make my sword yet, though.
Wooden board.
Yeah, I guess I'll craft an old one.
An old workbench.
How goofy.
How goofy is that...
that I need the primitive workbench.
I don't have a spear one, so...
We could make the medieval medicine one.
Pow medicine.
Interesting.
Put your stones away, please.
Normally I would have said no, but because you said please.
I'll make, like...
I don't know.
15?
but don't tell me what to do next time unless you say please
if you say things kindly i might listen
a little oh kindness goes a long way all right what is it uh
quick stack no duplicate items quick stack okay there we go
Anything in here?
Quick stack.
I'm hacked.
I'm getting burnt by my own fire.
Well then, I guess what's the best way to level up so that
we can unlock wooden boards, right?
Because...
Me and my 5,000 pounds of stone.
Look, I didn't get these arms just messing around, you know.
You want to know how I got these arms?
Catching pals.
Okay, let's go catch some pals, baby.
Five of each pal.
Were you guys like mega Pokemon catchers, you know?
Were you guys like mega po- Like, for me, I always was just
like a type where it's like...
If I had one, I didn't need any more, you know?
Oh, shoot, we're too good.
Okay, never mind.
I need to...
My bed.
I just tried to fill my decks.
Me too!
Oh, come here.
Hold up.
I'm just gonna...
Just gonna... Oh no!
Stop!
Oh, we aggroed that guy.
From all the way over here?
Why are you mad?
Okay, let's go find some better guys.
Tell them to be peaceful.
That's true, yeah.
Just a little bit more.
I like punching my guys.
Oh my god, ow!
I want to use a Megasphere on that.
Palisphere.
There we go.
Yeah!
Alright, let's get it.
Oh.
You're still on me.
Who hurt you?
Oh, that's not what I meant to do.
No, no!
There we go.
Alright, we're capturing guys.
We're capturing guys.
This is where I died.
I tried making it to that rock there.
And then I died right in front of it.
It was quite unfortunate.
He does zero damage.
No way, did he?
He didn't do any damage to me.
That's kind of funny.
My bad.
You need a swim pal.
I needed any- I was literally- I had nothing.
I needed anything.
Noink.
Fun.
I need to find a place where I can spend all my cash.
Grid.
Oh, he's aggroed too.
That's fine.
Whoa, my gosh, you're fast.
Whoa, my gosh.
All right, we're catching things, even if they're useless
things.
I'm, I'm, you know, I'm a...
Fox Spark seems to be struggling with their tasks.
I'm just trying to get more XP.
I'm already pretty low level, I feel, so catching low level
things is...
Level 38!
You think we could do it?
You can try.
Just like how this guy is.
Struggled against that 26th Catrass.
You're so right.
He's going to squash me.
Guys, I think I'm about to get squashed.
Guys.
Oh my god.
He killed us.
Wait, he killed him for...
Oh my god, he's...
He's freaking dead!
He's...
He killed him, I killed him!
For real!
Oh my god!
He died for real!
Alright, let's, uh...
I guess we'll fast travel to like, um...
Wait, we could drive this park.
Pen King.
He's just a few levels above me.
Or we could do the Chill It.
Let's do the Chill It.
I want my own.
We helped Limu get one last time, and I want mine.
My own.
You can slide down the hills with C.
Good to know.
Thank you.
Chill It is I think this way, actually.
I'll go up here.
Was it this way?
Yes.
I vaguely Oh,
I'll take some wool.
Noink.
Was it this way?
Yeah.
Up that bridge.
I think maybe...
Oh, up there, yeah.
Let's see.
How do I want to get up there?
Hmm.
Don't forget to switch your pal.
Yes, thank you.
Hello?
Random lightning?
That was weird.
Oh my dear!
Come here.
Yoink.
Wait, did I grab that?
Yeah, okay.
Sorry, I feel so scatterbrained today, guys.
Like, we're getting everything.
How do I get up here?
oh he's cute he's so cute oh oh can i do it with my deer
let's try it oh come on come on you could do it yes yes yes
yes nice yeah he's got the double jump
Nice baby.
Rank up.
Somebody did.
Oh, excuse me.
Is it this way?
Yes.
Does it not respawn?
Oh, no, just kidding.
That's funny.
We're gonna switch to you.
Alright, here we go.
And then once it gets too low, we'll call back.
Or put into peaceful.
Uh, maybe peaceful now.
And, oh, did not mean to, oh, it's fine.
Nope, not yet.
Ouch!
Wait, where am I?
Where?
Where is it?
Oh.
Ow, challenge.
I wonder if I need a better ball.
Hmm.
Uh oh.
Uh
oh.
I might die.
I might die though.
No, maybe not.
All right.
Oh, that was scary.
We're close-ish to level 14.
Close-ish.
Let's eat some berries.
Good job fuck sparks.
Good job.
We can ride the chill it too.
I think.
I'll just keep capturing guys.
Wait, this thing's cute.
Come, Ariel.
No!
Where are you going?
Stop running!
Did I get it?
I don't even think I'm hitting it.
you as it should it will be mine yeah creature you're mine
come here you're mine I want you in my party why are you
running he was tanky though I think I actually was just not
hitting him properly I think I was just I was hitting rocks
and stuff.
Alright.
Well, I wonder if I should catch more of these fox guys.
They're a little tough.
I almost died once before.
Trying to get one before.
Level 7.
I might be able to.
Read the Leaf Monk's description.
Opalpedia.
Intelligent.
as a five to seven year old human child.
It makes a wonderful partner, but there have been more than
a few cases where they've killed their master after learning
to use weapons.
Oh, I did level up.
No, not yet.
I need to get to 15 anyway.
Let's keep...
Alright.
We're stronger now.
Okay.
Wait, wait, wait.
Maybe?
Yahoo!
Oh.
Oh, the thugs!
The thugs are being mean!
We can get these guys.
We can take them out.
Come on.
I got an achievement for capturing a human!
That felt good.
I got, I'm gonna put, I'm gonna put him to work.
Oh, he gifted me a peach.
Thanks.
Wait, you cooking anything good?
No?
I actually leveled up now.
Good job.
Good, good, good, good.
Let's enhance my stamina.
Stamina is always so important.
Chloe.
Wait until she learns you can capture merchants and cops.
Are you winning, Minto?
Once I make my things, I feel like I'll be winning.
Oops.
I need it.
Oh, ow.
Mine?
Oh, that was close.
I think he was about to die.
Yahoo!
Hey, wake up.
You're mine now?
So close.
Capturing merchants were the meta.
What does that mean?
We welcome Mr. Human as a fellow Aibu.
Wait, what?
Oh, wait.
Let's fast travel somewhere.
Wait, what are those?
Nox.
Oh, they're cute.
I've never been here before?
I want one.
You're mine.
Mine.
Come on.
Yes.
If you find Nox here and you're betting you should leave it
where it lays and leave immediately.
Picking one up is a one-way ticket to a never-ending night.
To capture more.
Let's get this guy.
Your brother.
Oh.
Sorry, buddy.
My bad.
I'm too strong.
Set your pals to peaceful.
No, it's fine.
It's fine.
Oh.
But I killed it.
Whoa, but I killed it, but I killed it.
It's kind of crazy.
What is this?
Is this a person?
Are you alive?
Oh.
Uh, nope.
Wait, what's this?
Are these arrows?
We're winning.
Ghost Fox, yeah.
Oh, look at that means...
That's why they're dead.
I'm going to capture this guy too.
It wasn't me, it wasn't me.
There is no peace in Capito.
Hmm.
Hulcretis.
Hulcrites.
Wait, there's that tree.
I wanted to check out this tree before.
I remember seeing it.
There's just so much to explore.
Selling humans to a merchant is very lucrative.
Actually, I don't think I've even found a merchant yet.
I don't even know where one is.
I think I have to find a village.
Hulcretis, you live today.
Actually, no you don't.
You're mine.
Oink.
I love seeing the really jank pals just like moving in the
background.
It's very funny to me.
What is this tree?
I've never been to it before.
What do you do?
What the kind of...
Water, wait.
Am I picking one?
Aqua.
I'm sorry for dying in front of you.
Vicky and PVA off-ky from meet group.
Was it my intention?
You're fine.
I did get water.
I don't have good lot of luck.
Glad I could say you guys are great and the content was due.
Thank you!
Oh my inventory's full!
No!
I can't take this guy either then.
The electric egg.
Oh yeah, my inventory is full.
Let's get rid of these.
Egg.
I ate some baked berries.
I don't think I've gone this way.
That's a huge lie.
Yes, I have.
Wait.
I have?
Huh?
Hill of beginnings.
Wait, is this...
Wait, this isn't the start of...
Wait, where am I?
Oh, there's my base!
I'm a big old dummy head.
Okay, hold on.
Where am I?
What's here?
Oh, wait.
Yeah, we gotta go fast travel at an eagle.
I'm at the starter zone.
How embarrassing.
There's one down here.
Actually, which is closer?
My homer.
Hmm.
I got totally all turned around.
This one might be closer.
Oh, go drop your stuff.
Oh, yeah, I'll fast travel to the base.
That's fine.
And then from the base, I'll fast travel.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, I'm at inventory's full.
We're going to base.
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
Nice, nice, nice.
Yeah, I gotta remember to slide down the hills, huh?
Quick stack!
How is it?
How are we going here?
Many ingots!
Okay, okay!
We can make the metal helm!
I want it and I want I want the sword.
Oh, this is gonna take a while.
Oh wow.
Stop!
Leave me alone!
Thank you!
Going to a convention and cosplay for the first time
tomorrow!
I'm excited but also very anxious.
Have so much fun!
Call Daisy out.
Wait.
Help me out.
My B-Day tonight can I get a B-Day song?
Seeds Turtle!
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy Bappy!
Seeds Turtle!
Happy Bappy.
Alright.
all.
Oh, we're over halfway there.
Oh, whoa.
Over halfway there.
We're so close.
We're almost 75%.
But if this was how the song went, and then we just kept
progressing, and we're almost there.
We're over halfway there.
We're almost there.
like a 90 it's almost done oh yeah stinky lime whoa whoa
we're so close oh we're over halfway there whoa whoa we're
feeling down because of bad working conditions oh oh wait i
need to make an onsen thank you everybody else is in good
condition except this guy because he's getting overworked.
My bad.
What was the other thing I was trying?
Oh, the life pendant.
I need bone.
Make a hot tub.
Yeah.
Wait.
What's a hot tub under?
Oh, here we go.
Oh, now I can make it for real.
Alright, pals.
Um, where do we want it?
We'll put it by their bit.
Insufficient material.
What do you mean, though?
Oh, here we go.
Alright, everybody.
Three, two, one!
Oh, me too, me too.
Oh.
Pal box upgrade available.
Oh!
Wait, I completed a mission.
I didn't even know.
Let's go!
He's taking a break.
Yes, water my berries.
Yes.
Water my berries.
Yes!
hold on I know what to name him wait how do I name him wait
how do I name him he's
our sloppy slave yes water my berries sloppy slave do thy
bidding yes yes mine my Or sloppy slave.
Yes, keep working.
Got a lot of berries in there.
I wonder if they'll eat those too.
Wait, I can't give them more berries.
Nice.
What else was I doing?
Where did I get these from?
Are you good here?
You're so close to finishing.
You got this.
Actually...
I'm gonna give him a couple more.
Where did...
Flame organ?
Cool.
Only if they run out of berries.
Oh, okay.
Oh, whatever.
Um...
I thought...
I had more ore.
But alas, I do not.
Um... my sword.
I'm a bit out of ore now, I think.
So let's go grab some more.
When did I get a group frag grenade?
Wait.
Oh, this is stone.
Just kidding.
When did I get a frag grenade?
Hello?
Hmm.
Chickens are really freaking out.
We didn't board to level 15.
I know, I know.
Not yet.
Oh.
It was the goods dropped it.
All right.
Let's get a little bit more ore.
I said a little.
All right.
That's good enough.
Yes.
I did see that the people were doing, or like, Lai-Mu and
stuff was, they were doing the base missions.
I want to look at it.
again because i couldn't tell he's scaring me he's like
running around and i'm thinking that somebody's in my game
oh bet build a medieval medicine workbench oh we got this
wait we can easily do this we can easily do this over here
wait i no hold uh i i lied i lied build
No, there it is.
Medieval medicine.
They looked so similar at the time.
Wrong one.
Yeah, yeah.
I got it.
Look, he's helping me!
He's reformed!
You hated me.
You remember when you were attacking me last night?
You got like a crazy gun.
And then we build another berry.
Wait, can I build berries?
Do I need the technology for that?
Maybe I didn't unlock it.
Oh yeah, I didn't unlock it.
Hey.
Wait, where is it?
Berry Plantation.
Here we go.
Build it right here.
Oh.
Oh, oh, oh.
You gave him a job.
I think, I think, being a...
a bandit is a totally respectable job.
Oh wow, we have so many things in here too.
Alright, let's upgrade our base.
Pals without pal beds will get stressed.
Oh, I need to build a pal bed.
Did I get some?
Did I get some fiber?
Nope, I don't know.
Oh, I did get some fiber.
Okay, good, good.
Build bed.
It's always damn fiber.
fiber.
It does feel that way, huh?
You can shred wood.
Base upgrade.
Oh yeah!
Now the sphere workbench.
Deploy a work pal to the base.
I'm wondering who I should get rid of, you know?
Who I should switch out.
I want my chillit with me.
It's so cute.
Now you're going to need another bed.
You're right.
The cat.
My cat.
But he gives me more more carrying capacity.
Drop Capriti.
Maybe.
I don't know.
We have a second daisy.
Capriti can be base pal.
Oh wait.
This guy I seriously just Stinky Doki is living up to your
name.
You're so annoying.
You're so annoying and stinky.
I wanna see my chill it.
Cute.
Come back.
Wait, I need a saddle for you.
Cleaver him.
Wait, that's so bad.
That's so bad!
Uh...
I'm glad I can make the fire arrows, too.
That's pretty nice.
Oh, wow.
I need more Inget.
That's right.
We went and got some.
10.
Very good, very...
Okay, when can I get the saddle for...
I want that.
Saddle for chill it.
Oh, here it is.
Oh my god, wait, I can turn this guy into a machine gun!
That's crazy.
Bear trap small.
Statue of power.
Oh, I should get the small feed bag so then I can get the
average feed bag.
Oh, we can make the mega sphere.
Oh, there's the sphere workbench!
Okay, we're killing it.
We're killing it, guys.
We're killing it.
Okay.
One of the things was build a sphere workbench, no?
Oops, that's not what I meant.
Uh, base upgrade.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, we got the fox flamethrower, too.
So, isam?
Select recipe.
No, it's always fiber.
It's always fiber.
This is so crazy!
What?
Oh my god!
We should make this, though.
My chillits just being so cute over there.
You have a crusher near the cliff.
Oh, for the wood, right?
Yes, yes, yes.
Thank you, thank you.
Welcome to the grind, baby.
Alright.
Let's crush some wood.
Wait, is it... Does it come out of the chests?
Yes!
I don't know how much I should make.
Maybe like 25.
Oh, wait, hold on.
Sorry.
Uh, my YouTube just crashed.
My YouTube just crashed.
Guys, I think I like Power World.
Uh-oh.
Wait, hold on.
We're here.
Are you guys here?
I see you.
Kind of.
I'm reading you through OBS.
It is struggling to get back to me a lot.
Okay.
Awesome.
Oh.
Nice.
It's working.
Who's managing this thing?
You?
Go, little guy.
Go.
You're doing a crazy job.
Okay.
Um, sphere workbench.
That's right.
We're building.
Sphere workbench.
Yes, yes, yes.
This base is like all over the place.
It's a little bit all over the place, but don't mind it.
Don't mind it.
Quick while she can't see us.
I see you.
Yay.
Yeah.
All right.
Let's go upgrade our base again.
We're killing it.
I think I'm doing a fine job contributing now.
Before, I was doing like nothing.
Now, now I am contributing.
I am a participating member of society, I'd say.
Okay.
What else did I...
It was, let's see,
more cloth.
Cloth, we need to, uh, here.
Nah, you don't see us.
No fibbing.
No, I'm not even joking.
I'm not even joking.
Somebody help.
Help!
I got no one here to help.
You're doing a good job.
Yeah, Minto is no longer a POW world NEET.
Hey!
NEET!
I was not a NEET!
I was just confused.
Wait!
I thought... Wait!
You can call me a POW world noob!
But NEET!
Summon the cat to help.
It's fine.
It doesn't take that long.
The saddles, they auto...
I'm guessing they auto...
Auto equip, right?
What a neat.
Yeah, perfect.
My chilla is so cute.
Alright, what else do we want to do?
I'm 3,000 points away from getting to level 15.
I think you're pretty neat.
pretty neat same brain cell same brain cell acquire these oh
whoops that's not what i meant to burst at all i was quick
stacking that's what i was doing no duplicates okay some
fiber did we get all the fiber from here oh our guy is
taking a bright a little break all right maybe oh i'm hungry
too i'm hungry and game and in real person oh my head wait
how do i put this on oh that's not my oh this is my thing
wait it looks so good it looks so good
it looks so awesome wait i look like i look like um oh my
gosh what's her name from uh from Zeno not Zeno blade Zeno
gear um
Cosmos yes I look like Cosmos yes wait this is Zeno gear
Zeno saga oh my gosh there's too many Zenos Zenos but yes it
is Cosmos the robot yeah she wears this exact thing What is
she from, though?
Zenosaga.
Where's this exact one?
I'm hungry.
In-game.
And in real life.
I'm quite hungry, actually.
I should stop playing so I can eat.
But I can't stop.
It's a problem.
Wait, let's put away this egg.
Alright.
Wait, how's my egg doing?
Comfortable.
one hour still gonna get some burger you betcha you betcha
why did I yap for so long at the beginning I should have
been playing I should have been playing let's I want to get
let's get to level 15 and make my sword and then I'll feel
good so from here whoops that's not what I want to do we can
let's tell port too.
Maybe we can get this Pen King.
Let's try that.
Let's try the Pen King.
Nice yapp though.
I miss you guys so much.
I like yapping with you guys.
I'm playing games with you guys.
I'm just hanging out with you guys.
Thanks for hanging out with me.
Thanks a bunch.
Where is he?
Oh, Pen King.
Is it this one?
Yes.
Oh, is this him?
Sealed Realm of the Frozen Wings.
Oh, it's a dungeon!
Let's go.
We missed you, too?
There's a setting in Options Game Settings where you can
turn on...
You can make all held interactions into a single button
press.
That's all that's here?
Is just him?
Don't hurt my chillit!
Oh, my chillit's taking mega damage.
Oh, oh, oh.
Ouch, y'all.
Whoa!
Oh, shoot.
Wait.
Wait, I said I'm out of ammo.
That's not possible.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, gosh.
Wait.
Okay.
I'm gonna die in here.
Wait.
No, I have to come back in here to get him, right?
To get my stuff?
Uh, hello?
Roll me
to roll.
I forget.
I forget to roll.
Let's go get my stuff.
Kill the minions first.
Yes, maybe.
Maybe we don't do chill it.
Maybe we...
There's my stuff.
It's okay.
My first time doing a...
They fall.
That's my first time doing this.
Mm-hmm.
Oh.
Uh, dungeon by myself.
We learn.
The little bosses also get tricky.
I'll do my best.
We're like slightly underleveled.
Dear Anzo, welcome to my membership.
Thank you.
Oh, they're all asleep.
Oh, that's not.
Wait!
Oh no, I missed.
Come on.
Thought that bonus though.
You're mine now?
No, no, he's mine, he's mine.
He's mine, he's mine.
What?
Hicken...
Stubborn little guys, aren't they?
Yippee!
Okay, alright.
Nope, that's not what I wanted to do.
Not you.
Alright, here we go.
Ouchie, ouchie.
How's he doing?
Oh gosh, Adir is not doing good on health.
Oh.
Uh, that's all...
Just distract him!
Oh, that's not what I meant to do.
Wait.
Uh...
Let's do the hypersphere.
We'll do the hypersphere.
Wait.
Oh, this is not so bad.
No way!
No!
Oh my gosh!
First clear!
How did we leveled up?
Wait.
Oh my god, we killed it!
We killed it!
What?
That was crazy!
That was with a regular ball!
Sorry, this guy's...
And then I just leave?
Is that it?
Man, don't mind him, yeah.
Is there nothing else in here?
Doesn't seem like it.
Oh, oh, oh.
Wait, um, wait.
I'm so lost.
Wait, wait, where am I?
What's so happening?
Oh, God.
Let's get out of here.
So enter a dungeon when everything's asleep.
I've learned the strat.
Penking is a really good work or two.
Let's go.
Yahoo!
Wait, let's teleport home.
Who didn't need the dodge roll?
me who didn't need to roll me and let's heal my horse spank
thank you look at that two check marks down why is this guy
so tough we're like such a beginning area who took down the
pen king that one the sleep strat does not work with dark
pals oh good to know Everybody's asleep.
Wait, are there enough beds?
No, we don't have enough beds.
My pals are gonna get stressed.
Wait, what was it?
How did I build it again?
Uh...
Wait.
How do I...
How do I build a bed again?
I can't remember.
Infrastructure.
Ah!
Thank you.
Don't get stressed.
Uh, whoops.
I just missed it.
The human man can sleep on the ground.
No, he's one of us.
We have to treat him well.
He's one of us.
Wait, what is this?
Oh, you sons of bitches!
I wanted him.
It was tough because he was in the base.
Everybody wanted a piece.
What are you doing?
Oh, you're repairing.
Good job, buddy.
Gotta build another bed.
Oh, you're so right.
Thank you.
Oh, man.
It's so tough.
being being working here right am I right
being the I have unused stat points oh wait it's time
everybody to make a fishing rod and a wooden board okay well
eye on the prize eye on the prize
what do i need fiber it's always fiber
mill for the base it's okay someone else can do the the base
upgrade to be honest let's see did i get enough for it yes
how much do i need for it four wooden boards no oh we're so
close okay time eat your fiber for real though eat your
fiber for real okay acquire these select recipe
beginner rod oh my gosh it's a chill it rod even that's too
cute
yeah i just need one more nail which we should be able to
make easily because it's just uh just some ore probably oh
thank you for your help and then another thing one thing I
want to do is take chill it and go that direction because as
you can see I have not explored this area so much honestly
this map is crazy thou shalt not harm pals no why would I
make a cleaver and eat them that's so weird why would you
ask that uh wooden board wooden board wooden board i need
more ingots no no what was i making sorry i'm getting lost
in the sauce wooden board i need more fiber okay i'm
getting hungry so i'm like getting lost in my brain you know
what i mean
working here he likes it he does a good job watering thank
you very much sir is that all I needed oh why is there so
much stone on the ground he doesn't have to be he doesn't
have to be a bandit that that that robs people for food we
feed him berries Hungy, it's time for Donner.
No, no.
Dinner party.
I need my ore.
Oh my gosh, it's time to ore farm again, guys.
Gunslinger no more.
Does he get paid?
Absolutely.
The Donner party goes crazy.
All right, we need quite a bit more ore, actually.
Oh, before I head out, I want to get my horse.
This guy just mines and doesn't do anything.
Do you see this?
Buddy, pick it up.
My god.
Holy cow.
That ain't his job.
We are fighting dreamers.
let me use my stat points I'm going to do more stamina
stamina is huge oh let's get my horse oh no he still needs
four minutes okay never mind we'll take I don't know we'll
just go all I want to do is explore to be honest or actually
maybe I should get the ore so that guy can be working on it
while I'm gone
yeah ride the chile it i will i will that's what i was
planning on doing but i wanted to have a full party is all
okay here we go thanks
for making it say a little bit brighter hi chocolate pie
eater thank you does your little guy have a machine gun now
no i didn't make it for him but i should
this is all we need this is all we need yes yes who's doing
six six six five dog thank you so much for that hug or
something what the heck we'll have to see you back in
enjoying power world legends was amazing so proud of mvp oh
thank you thank you so much thank you
Alright, now we just make the ore.
And we go adventuring a little bit.
That should be enough.
Right?
20?
20 of them should be enough for this.
I think it was exactly 22.
Wait.
24!
Holy cow!
That's crazy.
We're riding, we're riding.
Nice.
All right.
This is great.
Chill it.
How good are you at falling?
There we go.
Oh!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh!
Oh, yeah!
Oh my gosh!
We're doing it!
We're zooming.
Is this...
Oh my gosh.
I feel like this is how it feels to ride a Lapras for real.
You know what I mean?
Flying fish coast Yeah, this is so fast.
Careful about stamina.
I think we're okay.
Let's go.
Quick noodle.
What the?
Yeah!
Oh, cleared.
What did I clear?
Wait, I was going to catch it.
Wait, what happened?
Pick up?
Oh my god, it's hair schematic again.
What's this over here?
Oh, wait, this is to upgrade our...
Shiny fish!
We need this to upgrade.
Yoink!
Effigy.
Oh my god, get up.
up girl now how do i fish
the tower sometimes spawn pals to fight oh you need bait i
have bait i have bait wait did i put the bait away no no no
i have a simple bait i have a simple bait where's my where's
my rod go oh here accessory
what do i need fishing rod you'll put the rod in a weapon
Oh, okay, okay.
No!
Okay, there we go, there we go, there we go.
We got this.
Get out of my way, I can't see.
My first fish.
What just happened?
Oh,
you click!
I thought something else would pop up.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, oh, oh!
Oh, okay, okay.
My first fish!
Oh, God.
Horrifying.
Hold on, I gotta eat some more.
Wow, I caught 20 kinds of pals.
I gotta eat some more.
I'm getting so hungry.
Why was he dead?
Why'd he die?
What is this?
Requires riding a pal and equipping a fishing rod.
I got that.
Yeah, I'm literally doing that.
Am I not...
Is Chillit not a water pal?
He's not?
Oh, he's an ice pal.
Aw, man.
What's this thing?
Looks like a giant gun.
Can I go in?
Ooh.
Find 10 new areas.
This area is scary.
Be careful of the red light.
We'll go.
We're chill, we're chill.
We're chill it, we're chill it.
24!
You think I could sneak past him?
Maybe we hold off.
They don't aggro.
Am I gonna get one guide?
That was close.
I meant to F.
He might leave you alone.
Yeah, we're good, we're good.
What I wanted to do, let's check out this shiny right here.
What's here?
What is this?
What are you?
Wait, can I mine this?
Or is it a...
Is it this axe?
Whoa, oh, ancient bark!
Whoa!
Very nice.
Is wood.
I learned that.
You learned things the hard way.
Very nice.
Don't get mad at me.
So that's where you get ancient bark.
Happy to help.
Wow.
It's so cool in here.
Whoa!
Wow!
Oh my gosh!
I don't piss this bitch!
Hello men, thanks for the off-climb me and the greet.
I hope it is memorable to you as it is to me, however.
I'm afraid you have serious charges on your permanent record
based on our findings from the inspection.
And no, you can't hamster dance your way out of it.
No, please!
It was very funny.
Thank you for the fine.
Whoa, wait, what level are you?
What level are you?
Yeah, every time the Idol Business Regulation Agency would
try to ask me for an explanation.
Uh-oh.
I would go.
Oh, they're fighting.
The girls are fighting.
Maybe I can get in there and...
Maybe?
Oh, yes!
We third party?
Oh, my inventory's full.
Wait, maybe I can eat...
Um...
Maybe I can...
Oh, shit.
We gotta go.
Debbie Raid!
Whoa!
Hi!
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Hello, the beats.
Wait, Cali, you've ridden me.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
We're fine, we're fine, we're fine.
I got so distracted.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm gonna eat some raw meat.
We're good, all right.
Hello, hello.
Wait, what was Cali playing?
Hi, Calliope.
Howdy, howdy, Raiders.
I'm playing Powell World for the third time ever.
We're fine.
That other thing was more aggressive than that guy.
Buff me.
Yeah, you like my arms?
I skipped Leg Day, though.
I skipped Leg Day on accident.
thank you guys for all the gifted thank you so much thank
you thank you i think we can go through here look i even got
a rare deer
where are you going where are you going where are you gonna
do in there
silly the area you're called in is a wildlife sanctuary look
out for the flying drones that'll pretty much instantly kill
you.
Wait, I made it out so lucky then.
Wait.
So many gifts.
Yeah, thank you, everybody.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
Strike drones.
Wait, I completely...
I don't even know there was anything in there.
I made it out so lucky.
We're in the sea, breeze, archipelago.
Archipelago.
Hey little guys Cat of us Very nice Sanctuary 1 has no
drones Only 2 and 3 have drones Oh Wait what are you Creamus
Big guy Wait we can take this guy on We can take this guy on
Oh shoot wrong button What Did not mean that.
We can do this!
One has a drone.
It does?
Yeah!
Oh, wrong thing.
Why am I hot?
Area 1 has one drone.
Oh, wait!
We might just be the real lucky pal in the world.
Yahoo!
Yeah,
I'm hot!
Why is it so toasty?
Is this area toast?
That guy is just in the wall.
I love this game.
He's so funny.
It's the dress.
Oh, put away Foxparks.
Why am I being hurt by my own pal?
I want to love him, but...
Oh my gosh.
Is there a...
I wonder if there's a...
teleportation fast travel oh is that him literally am i
literally looking at him
what the oh i guess he got out of i didn't realize that's
what he looked like oh
i'm gonna ride in my chilla even though he's not as fast on
land
To the right.
Fast travel.
Oh, there's a cave right there.
What are you?
Flambé?
Is this a dungeon?
I don't really want to go in, though.
Level 13, boss.
It's faster than walking.
That's what I'm saying.
Why am I hot?
Well, look at you.
It's summer, baby.
summer oh what are you oh you never old okay let's get out
of here that guy is tough that guy too tough for me there's
so much to explore i want to find everything everything
nice so many trees to chop down This is not fast travel,
unfortunately.
Where's the fast travel thing?
The game is stacked with content.
Truly it is.
Like, actually, it's kind of crazy.
Get off.
I'm hacking.
Find the correct position.
Okay, we got this.
Wait.
Oh, I was about to say first try.
That was crazy.
Okay.
Holy cow!
We were so close.
Handgun.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Get rid of everything else.
Get rid of the venom gland.
Get the discarded.
We need to get home so I can put my schematics away.
Really good early drop.
Holy cow!
We need to find a faster travel.
Let's just keep heading this way, I guess.
Maybe we'll find one eventually.
Usually there's like...
I don't know.
Fast travel!
Nice.
Yeah, please read the books they unlock stuff.
Yeah, I will eventually.
Reading?
reading alright has the egg hatched yet we can check they
show up on their radar when they're closest yeah yeah that's
why I kept checking my map but nothing had showed up 40
minutes seems very comfortable how's our how's our place
doing oh that's right unfold what books do I even have this
guy training manual training manual that grants a large
amount of exp when read by a pal how about who do i want to
in this one too allowing a pal to read it permanently
increases their kindling affinity by one plus who do i want
this is so i guess we can okay hold on
how old is so fine i'll be doing my six to six job while my
friends use my pals to make eggs and get them pregnant i'm
getting crowned in the chair What does that mean?
If you're getting crowned that means you're the king
Kindling is the furnace speed.
Oh, I thought it was like oh That makes sense.
Wait, then we'll use it on Fox.
Wait Not our Fox sparks.
Oh, this one This Fox sparks Not ours wait, I'm gonna oh I
was gonna say I'm about to run out of room but that's not
the case at all.
I'm going to replace this guy.
Sorry, Stinky Doki.
Look, I got even this fancy guy.
No, D is good again.
Rip, Stinky.
Now he's taunting me and playing his giant.
Now he's...
You can use the floor menu to feed the books.
Oh, really?
That's what I was trying to do.
Four.
Wait.
Oh, it's time for sleep.
Look at this.
He's massive.
He's suffocating everybody.
Wait, do we have enough yet?
Wait.
Oh, gosh.
I gotta put away my schematics.
Here, we'll make it so anybody can make the thing.
stuff we'll make it so anybody can make it not no actually i
want the gun i'm being greedy on that one here we go guys
time wait how much do i need for the gun oh i guess i have
to unlock it huh time to make a sword
you have ammo i have some ammo different bench to make it
got it oh wow this is gonna wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait let's sleep well we need at least some assistance on
this one wait wait summon the cat everybody's asleep
everybody's asleep it wouldn't matter I
think sorry okay summoning summoning my cat all right
everybody come on this is going to take forever bless you
thank you wait oh my gosh this is going to take forever
This is the same starter base spot I picked.
It's got a nice view.
I think from what Limu said, this is like the base spot that
most people pick.
Need better pals with better hands.
No.
What you getting on your burger?
I'm gonna get.
Wait, is it safe to eat lettuce again?
Is it safe?
I'm gonna get Borger I just really want the grilled onions
No No It's never safe What does that mean?
I think we're good I had some at Offkay Como, you know it's
a two week incubation period, right?
You can opt for no lettuce if you're worried Maybe I miss
eating greens.
I guess it's only lettuce, though.
Lettuce is kind of like the least of the greens.
Honestly, it's good that it's lettuce.
Because it's like...
It's a report to y'all.
But if you cook your...
If you cook your lettuce, it's fine, right?
If you cook your greens, it's fine, right?
Iceberg lettuce is the leastest of the least.
Exactly, exactly.
If I can have spinach, I'll be okay.
I'll be okay.
I love a bag of spinach.
I'll eat like the whole bag of spinach.
I become Popeye.
That's why I look like this in the game, probably.
Yeah, I cook...
Okay, I cook my spinach in sesame oil.
This is, this is my, this is my, this is my, this is my, my
made fact.
Cook your spinach and a little bit of sesame oil.
And it's the delicious.
It makes sense.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That sounds pretty tasty.
It's arugula's time to shine.
Gotta try peanut oil.
Whoa.
Peanut wheat.
What?
Wait.
What do you mean?
Wait, what's that mean?
Arrayed!
Are you helping?
Oh no, he's watering.
Um, um, I need my sword, I need my sword!
Wait.
A bunch of enemies are going to attack the base.
Wait, how many enemies are we talking?
Welcome Raiders!
This will finish in time, maybe.
I don't think so.
Um.
You have five minutes.
I have less than.
I have less than five minutes.
Wait, I'm scared.
Like 20.
20!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, what?
You can also kill him to start the raid immediately.
Well, then you'd better brace yourself.
Wait, they're scaring me.
They're scaring me.
We have mega, mega pals.
I think we're fine.
Oh my gosh, they approach and...
Okay, wait.
I'm scared.
We have some really good pals, I think.
Probably.
Oh my gosh.
Three minutes they approach us.
You have a dragon.
Yeah.
My pals will help.
Wait, if only I had...
No, my sword!
Oh, why are they coming?
Capture the guy for scaring you, right?
My sword's not gonna be ready in time.
If only I had my sword.
Oh!
The reward.
Boards are good so I would never cancel it.
Is it like that tough though?
Wait, I'm so scared actually.
I'm scared, I'm scared.
Base pals also fight back, okay.
It's not tough, the pals will carry.
We have some pretty good pals, we got some good pals here.
He'll be fine, okay, all right.
We got this guys, we got this.
We have two minutes.
Look at this, I'm doing so much for this base.
Quick me to activate your Do Do Lettuce powers!
I don't want that!
Level 8.
Okay.
Hard at work seems to be a good worker.
Alright.
Our pals are fed.
They're happy.
They're relaxed.
My sword is taking forever, though.
Should we just start it?
No, we have a minute.
Well, it's not going to get done in...
I don't want him to attack me too, though.
I forgot to tell you, the Turok trilogy is on sale on Switch
for 14 days.
Turok games are one of my favorite Doom style games,
especially too.
I've heard of them before.
I've heard of them.
He deserves it.
Wait, can I capture him?
Never mind.
Oops, I clicked cancel, but...
All right.
Uh.
Where are they?
Oh!
I'm scared.
Oh my gosh, look at all these rocks!
All right, everybody!
Wait, I'm hungry.
Oh, shoot.
Where are they?
Oh, they're going up.
Oh, oh.
Holy cow.
They're starting up here.
Oh, they're kind of strong.
They're a little bit strong.
Oh gosh, they're killing everything.
Let's summon you.
Wave cleared!
Yes.
Next wave!
This wave!
No, just kidding!
Back up here!
Oh.
I can't see.
Holy cow.
Rain defeated!
Oh, yeah.
Oh, yeah, baby.
All right, everybody, back to work.
Destroyed.
Absolutely crushed it.
There's so many rocks there.
That was pretty funny.
Everybody eat.
Everybody get a good meal after that.
That was pretty tough.
That was pretty scary.
Yeah, good job team.
Good job team.
Mother base defended.
Yeah.
Oh, we have a casualty on the base.
Oh, let's uh, let's bring my cat back out.
Come here.
Come on, come on.
We have a sword to make.
I never We're doubted for a second.
I'm a mad doubt.
You can press R with your inventory open, a quick stack of
everything.
Oh, to all the chests?
Oh, wait.
I think I misunderstood earlier then.
Ah, okay.
Oh, wait.
I forgot.
Oh, never mind.
I didn't misunderstand.
I just forgot about it.
Ah.
Yeah.
It's...
It ain't easy being...
Being cheesy and being overpowered and being...
Awesome.
See you all looking at chestworks too.
That's what I've been doing.
I mentioned that but had no more letters left.
No, I appreciate all the assistance, guys.
Thank you for creating...
For molding me into a POW world master.
Yes.
To goaded with the salus.
Sauce on my burger.
Okay.
What time is it?
Oh, I'm good, I'm good.
Once my sword is done, maybe.
How long will this take though?
Might need a better workbench.
You think so?
20 minutes!
Seven years.
I'm afraid it's been nine years.
Yeah,
I think it's going to take a long time.
I'm canceling it.
Alright, hold on.
Let's see.
Build.
What can I...
Maybe we can't...
Maybe we can...
Heat resistant pelt arm.
Mega shield.
Antique bathroom set.
Tombstone first.
Woohoo!
Wait, mega glider.
Wait, that's huge.
A toilet.
Oh, is it the weapon work bench?
Oh, man.
That'll be a long time until we can do that.
Just a worker with a higher handiwork, too.
Wait, lock picking.
Lock picking.
Wall torch.
Pick locking.
Heater.
on the right oh this nice yes wait what's that a hip lantern
wait that's awesome pal essence combine several pals at the
same time to create a higher ranked version we're fusing
pals wait the grappling gun okay okay hold on okay hold on
i'm just like talking i'm guessing this like yeah a lantern
that could be attached to the hip it lights up automatically
and now you can also switch his light mode it on at all
times.
Oh, yeah, I want that.
Nice.
Mega grappling gun!
Way!
Pacifist ring.
Whereas attacks will not reduce the target's health below
one.
Wait, that's huge.
A meow mare!
Oh, Ultra Kill Collab.
Wait, what?
Wait, wait.
Ultra Kill Collabs.
Actually.
I'm like going through the skill trees.
Wingpack.
Whoa.
I want everything.
Look at these get crazy down here.
What the heck?
Whoa.
We're going to look...
Cake.
Okay.
I think I've got my work cut out for me, don't I, huh?
I'm getting weighed down a little bit.
Let's take my sword back.
We'll put this away.
Sapphire.
Oh.
Ooh.
Oh, my ancient bark.
We can put that away.
I'll hold off on reading some of these just yet.
Hypersphere is mine.
Put the rock away.
So many.
ingots i know i know but they're mine um there were a lot of
collabs that's how they beat nintendo's lawsuit crazy work
once you gain the schematic you don't you learn it you don't
have to hold on to it yeah but i don't want anyone else
making a sword
it's mine it's mine it's my sword that's my sword we'll put
some of these materials in here though read it read the book
wait okay how do I make it that I can I mean we can save it
here no I feel like someone's gonna misuse it
you could make a chest and make it private yeah I'm saving
some of these I'm saving some of is wait i have so many
training manuals though i just realized training manual m
wait i have so many of the that's all i have so many of
these it's so funny here we'll get right wait is this a
human heart precious entrails very interesting here i'll
cook the lamb lamb kabob
use them up we'll use them
wait how much does that give you to?
nice oh nice nice dang dang okay guys I am Pongori Pongori
hungry hungry so I think it's my time to check out to to go
get some food this was a lot of fun I like pal world I think
we're we we are working on another date for another collab
oh my gosh they just knocked down everything and then they I
don't pick it up.
It's so funny.
Where can I put all this wood?
Wait.
There.
I don't know why I pressed R, but it didn't show anything.
That's strange.
I'm going to be a pro-next collab.
Yeah!
How about the egg?
We can check on the egg real quick.
It's probably, if I had to guess, like 20 minutes.
Yep, 23 minutes.
That's okay.
Still recovering from the jet lag myself, so I hope we can
rest up and be prosperous.
You deserve it after that great show.
We are, and thank you!
Thank you so much.
Thanks for coming to see you.
See you, Satya.
Good meet and greet.
Dorgo, thank you.
Great progress and nice of you to make beds for your...
Workers!
gal since you responded polite request pretty please eat a
super yummy and nutritious burger and have a very good night
thanks for the stream okay thank you thank you thank you i'm
glad you had fun at at of kai concert was amazing thank you
open your inventory press r then click the blue button oh
did i do it wrong wait i thought the things would show up oh
wait all my money Wait, my money, all my money, all my
money.
Yeah, it's whatever.
It's fine if we have to go hunting for more stuff.
All right.
Thank you guys for teaching me how to do more.
Oh gosh, we're about to get, we're about to get, oh.
Thank you for teaching me so many power world things and
helping me get caught up.
i'm gonna be i'm gonna be a real pro i think it'll be
awesome i'm gonna up my work speed a little bit
yeah thanks for the stream have a good boy girl thank you
thank you thank you this is so much fun this is so much fun
and um yeah you made it super fun for us thank you so much
thank you thank you guys thank you thank you so much have a
good day have a good night have a good
Oh yeah, I have an announcement tomorrow with my mama, Ayami
mama.
It's a pretty cool announcement, I'd say.
So yeah, I'll be collabing with her tomorrow for stream.
For stream, for stream.
Yes, yes, yes.
Pretty neat announcement.
Yay.
Yeah, well she, she, she, I was like, well, it's more of
Ayami's announcement.
But she was just like, I was like, are you sure it's your
big thing?
I'm just kind of a little bit a part of it.
But she insisted on my channel.
So, yeah.
Early morning?
No.
Should be same time.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
She loves you.
And I love her.
Yeah, she worked so hard for me.
She worked so hard in general.
For everybody.
So yeah.
Okay.
Thank you everybody.
Thank you.
Have a good day.
Bye bye.
Do we need to have our wallets ready for tomorrow?
No.
Not for tomorrow.
Honestly.
Only if you want to at all.
I'll explain tomorrow.
Bye-bye.